Holy fucking Shit,
we're doing it again,
folks.
Monday 2:30
PM,
2:37.
Exactly.
Los Angeles high aids,
higher aids content,
and the amt.
Brian has every known venereal disease
fighting it out for dominance inside of
his soul right now,
but I'm on zinc and magnesium.
He's taken Alpha brain that's keeping
them together.
What would you recommend in on its
category or different things for me
before you went?
I would say take a shitload of that.
Take a lot of coconut oil.
Coconut oil is shown to have
antibacterial and antimicrobial pro
qualities to it,
so you could take coconut oil,
rub it on your Dick,
and conceivably it protect you from a
few very unambitious,
stds,
Lazy Std.
Not like aggressive Ebola type super
aids.
Yeah,
it ain't going to fight that out,
but it might kick the shit out of
chlamydia.
You know what I'm saying?
I've been running rubbing a killer bee
honey on some of the sores.
That's good.
That's a good move.
We pull and sticky now.
That's great.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
Dot Com.
This is not bullshit.
We sell killer bee honey.
We also offer no evidence.
That's even better than regular honey.
We don't give a fuck.
The fact that we can sell the honey from
those gangster bees,
we stole it from them.
That's human dominance.
That's one for teen people.
I'll take that killer bee honey and you
can go fuck yourself.
Bees.
We win and they are not very good on
these sores though.
Like for real?
Not Good.
We'll just probably go to a doctor.
You probably have eight now.
You don't want to go to a doctor because
you don't want to know that you have
your patient zero.
Do you get ingrown hairs a lot though?
You get ingrown hairs because I'm a
hairy guy so I get is a lot.
Yeah,
I mean on your package now.
My packets.
But like around that area right on your
face.
Like I get them once in a while.
My face like my heavier in Shaden
shavings.
You don't look like you shave a lot man.
He's usually the cause of ingrown hairs.
Yeah.
Messing around with your hair when you
shave your right?
Yeah.
Especially if you use a blade.
That's the thing about
shaving it down.
The stubble you don't run the risk of
the,
the hair's getting stuck under the skin
because that's what happens.
It's an ingrown like grows in a fucked
up way and then pops out like a Zit.
But if you leave stubble that doesn't
happen.
Do you shave like from your butthole to
your balls like once every six months,
year,
three months,
like you know,
like that,
the whole taint area or do you do it?
Don't
do a full groom.
I do do the balls and the front package
and not usually like down to the bone
but this time I did because I fucked up
but it just cut it too low and it looks
stupid and I was looking at the hedges.
I was like,
this is a wrap.
I got to wrap this one up and I just
fucking buzz the whole thing.
So for the next couple of weeks I'm
going to look like a 12 year old.
But you know what I'm chicks dig that.
I'm checking.
Yeah.
At this point it doesn't matter.
You know who gives a fuck,
shave it off,
keep it,
just don't cut any patterns in it.
And I would say,
don't go with a razor.
That's where you're getting the
Gillette sensor to that.
Yeah,
you get sold
blow,
you know,
you're like exfoliating.
They say that's also one of the reasons
why men don't get those funky lines in
their face and near their mouth as much
as women do because of the shaving.
Exfoliates the skin.
It constantly creates a new level layer
of skin.
Whereas women don't get that opportunity
to shave.
So they get creepy old lady face.
Well,
what's getting big now?
You see all the stores that you like the
men's shaving,
like in the twenties where they sit you
down straight razor.
I've never done it.
I've had friends,
I've had friends that told me it's
awesome that he had a great experience.
I've never done it.
Car,
you just escaped death.
Now it's like jumping off a fucking
building.
Make It.
You make it.
It feels great.
It's got a knife right next to your
throat.
If you how?
How quick can you fight them off?
You're dead.
You're a dead man.
He's going to cut your throat.
You're fucked.
You know you're not going to be able to
fight that guy.
Oh God.
Father type shit.
Fuck.
He's got Ya.
It's not.
I'm not into that.
What can I avoid that?
Yeah,
I can write with one of those things.
Okay.
I'll take that thing over.
Jesus.
Sit down there with a doodle.
It's got a fucking sword.
Next year.
Neck.
Got Some Jack The ripper type shit.
I guess there's a bunch of Italians in
Vegas right now because there's this new
Italian museum that's opening up right
now,
the Italian museum.
So there's tons of Italians and mops.
Mafia kinda guys are in Vegas.
Mafia legend or they're just,
you know,
posters.
Yeah.
And it was the gun show this weekend.
And Avn.
Oh my God,
it was a fucking weird.
We should talk about that on the podcast
through this 10 commercial we're brought
to you by 10.
If you go to Rogan.ting.com,
you save 25 bucks off of either a phone
or,
or even their service.
You can apply it to their services as
well.
And they have some of the best,
uh,
Samsung Galaxy s three Samsung Galaxy
note to some of the best android phones
that are available.
Sounds sprint and or network
you,
you don't even know about this.
Yeah.
Tell me about the.
Announces a $100,000
etf payout fund,
which will reimburse switches up to $350
per line.
So what they're doing,
this is crazy.
This is insane that the phone companies
doing this,
this is huge.
They are pretty much like if you have a
contract with verizon,
if you cancel it's $350.
Usually it's like you're a year into the
contract and it's probably like $180.
What Ting is doing is if you switch over
to Qa Ting,
they will give you whatever that money
is as credit.
So pretty much like if you pay,
you have $150 at verizon,
they're giving you a $150 credit on
tings for all your,
your,
your use of a service through them.
So you won't have to pay anything for
$150 credit.
Conceivably get like a free year.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If you have $350 now pretty much have a
full year of free free cell phone,
sir.
That's,
that's very kind.
It is.
It's a very cool company and it's one of
the reasons why we,
uh,
we got connected with them.
I just love the fact
that they're trying to set up a company
that's not trying to fuck you.
And that's like in their mission
statement.
Not exactly,
but you know what I'm saying.
I mean I'm talking like a paraphrasing
and shit,
but the bottom line is they wanted to
make it so there's no contracts.
They want to sell you phones at a very
reasonable rate and they want to put you
on a good network.
Sprint is one of the best networks in
the country depending upon where you
live.
Every phones,
depending upon where you live.
I don't think there's any one provider
that hasn't nailed,
but a lot of people like and prefer the
CDMA network that sprints on over like
the t mobile GSM network or 18 and t GSM
network.
A lot of people say that,
uh,
the CDMA phones cut out less.
It's apparently it's older technology.
I'm too stupid to understand it,
but I know that people are pretty happy
with the sprint service and it's fucking
cheap.
You,
you also can set it up so that you have
one or more people can share an account
so you can share an account with your
wife so you can,
you know,
you could share minutes which is,
which is great,
you know,
if you,
if you don't use the phone that much.
And a lot of us today I fucking text a
lot more than I make phone calls a lot
more and that's the most important thing
to me is to be able to text and bill to
get on the Internet.
Like my actual phone calls per day.
I do in my mind when I'm in my car,
you know,
so I could get work done while I'm
driving,
but I'm not ready.
I'm not using it like I used to.
I text so much more now than talking on
the phone.
Which is weird because when you read
somebody texts,
you're reading it how you want to read
it,
like in your own head.
So it kind of makes me wonder if you are
kind of controlling who,
what people's opinions of you are.
Very deep philosophical way to look at
basically contorting my world.
You're imposing my worldview on the
people that are contacting me.
You're missing sarcasm.
Completely.
Think everybody actually does think
you're the shit.
Here we go quite a bit depending on the
number of texts you getting into.
Yeah,
go go to [inaudible] dot ting dot
comm.
Support a cool company that's uh,
that's there.
They're doing the right thing.
It's like,
I think the companies can make money and
not be consumed and Tang agrees and,
and that's why we have them as a
sponsor.
The one thing that will guarantee you
after,
I've said it a million times,
but I,
I have to repeat it.
We're never going to have someone
sponsor this show that we don't believe
in.
It's got to make some sense.
It's got to be a legit product.
And if it wasn't a legit product,
Brian and I will sit down and talk about
it and we would say,
fuck this.
Yeah,
we can't have these guys on.
This is stupid,
you know,
this is some bullshit.
So the people that were involved with as
least under our opinion,
it's all legit companies.
And if you're in a games,
one of our other sponsors is kerosene
games and kerosene games has.
They have.
The second game is about to drop.
They're there.
They're in the final stages,
I believe,
but the first game is called Blade
slinger and they're making all these
games for ipads and iphones.
So it's not like a pc game has been
over.
Instead,
it's a fucking real legit high end game
that's really cool to play.
It's fun.
It's cool to look at like visually
they're fun.
It's any you play on an ipad means it's
three bucks.
You just can't go wrong.
One apple editor's choice award and has
been rated for at a four must have by
many critics with a winning score of
other industry accolades for quality and
excellence.
People have been saying it's a fucking
bad ass game,
gets gets very good reviews.
You're always going to have to give a
few bad reviews and if it wasn't.
If I saw something that didn't have a
few bad reviews,
I'd be like,
you know what?
I don't believe them.
Don't trust it.
Yeah,
I think this is a dummy account.
You'd probably have to fucking pay
somebody to be able to post here because
there's always comes out there.
They're going to find something.
I've heard the greatest songs ever and
have people like,
oh my God,
that's whiny bullshit.
Like they'll.
They'll say something like that in the
youtube comments.
There's always going to be that guy,
so if you have something that's
universally praised that that sounds
ridiculous,
but that said,
the praise for this game has been pretty
strong.
People love it.
If you're in this first person,
third person,
right?
Because you first person would be
looking through his actual eyes.
I believe the finance game,
man,
I played this on the plane.
That's great for playing on the plane,
man.
You have your ipads.
I love.
I'm getting.
I'm using my.
I've had more and more lately.
Well,
you know what I love about
eight.
That is it.
You can take time.
That's bullshit time where you're stuck
in a fucking plane and you make it fun
and you can actually enjoy it.
Yeah.
So here is fucking some people up.
Anyway,
go buy that shit.
It's three bucks.
Alright,
your Fox.
We were also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com,
but we kind of talked about them.
The other thing.
So,
so,
uh,
go there o n n it used to code named
Brogan and saved yourself 10 percent off
any and all supplements.
And remember,
if you haven't heard this before on it,
it's another company that absolutely is
not trying to rip anybody off.
Sounded like I was sending you a secret
message that I'm lying.
Yeah.
I was actually just an inopportune
conference.
Drinking bulletproof coffee bitches.
This is grass fed butter.
Upgraded coffee in a blender with mct
oil because that's how Dave asprey
roles.
And he taught me these things.
So.
Well the only problem is when you drink
butter and coffee,
that's tickets fleming.
So when trying to talk tastes like
you've got to load in your mouth,
you're so oily.
I'm a little oily.
Um,
but the,
um,
the thing about honest is any of the
supplements you have 90 days,
100 percent money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the
product.
No one is trying to rip you off.
We're just selling you the very best
shit that we can find out there.
And in that,
whether it's exercise equipment,
whether it's supplements,
whatever it is,
we're trying to sell you the very best
shit and use a code name.
Rogan,
you will save 10 percent of any of the
supplements,
right?
You Fox.
Listen,
Jimmy Smith is here from Bella tour
fighting championships.
Was that other show requests,
requests from fight quests.
Quiches fellow MMA commentator.
We're going to break shit down.
Experience Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Powerful Jimmy Smith.
Whoa.
You just abruptly.
You got crazy today.
The super aids he caught in Vegas this
weekend.
It's affecting his mind's already
affecting his work.
Performance.
Settle.
This may be a.
How many of us on the planet Earth Dudes
who do five?
If you're generous five or six,
if you're a generous,
generous.
Yeah.
This like you,
me,
and of course Pat Miletich.
Yeah.
This is a very smart.
I mean frank,
frank,
shamrock.
It's like how many guys?
Stephan Bonner does it.
He does it.
Well,
you know Kenny does a good job.
It's not that many people doing that.
So strange Gig,
isn't it?
It's weird and I'm sure you get the same
thing.
What I try and tell a lot of people,
I had a lot of fighters with outstanding
careers.
We're seeing the retirement of the
second generation.
You may not,
not the founders in a hoist and the
second generation is starting to break
down and retire and I've had guys
literally coming up to me going,
how did you get this Gig?
Because if you think about it,
fuck,
did we get this job?
In a sense,
you know,
it's crazy,
but there are very few that actually do
it.
Yeah.
There's so few.
And for folks who don't know,
Jimmy does the commentary for Bella
tour,
which is the second biggest promotion in
the United States,
and they're there on spike tv now.
They've actually taken the position that
the UFC had and just had the first
fight.
So you've been around a long ass time,
man.
You've been doing commentary like for
for belt or for how long now?
Bella?
Towards three and one for six years.
I've been doing this.
I did anyone before before Bella tour,
so I did three years of commentary.
Nobody was listening to to get good at
it.
It was cool that you had a little bit of
experience doing television stuff
though,
but you were already loose enough.
Like your,
your,
your.
That's like a big thing for guys is just
figuring out how to loosen up so they
can explain themselves.
It's,
it's a weird gig because the only one
who's going to be able to do it is it's
not going to be possible unless you
don't.
Unless you train you,
you're not gonna,
you're not gonna.
Be able to see things you'll sound like
a Douche to.
Yeah,
I don't.
One thing that really personally bugs me
about commentary is when people question
somebody and they haven't been there
when it's.
When it's,
you know,
I got a lot of people question
somebodies heart or they get hit,
they go down from a body shot,
you've been hit in the liver,
you go down and if you've trained,
if you sparred,
you know that,
and people that don't and and I think
are hard on fighters and question our
heart,
a questionnaire design when they haven't
been there and gone through that.
That bugs me.
Yeah.
You know,
that does bug me.
That bugs me a lot.
What else bugs me is people saying that
they know who's gonna win.
That bugs me.
I mean,
I'll talk shit on occasion if like I
see a match up and I go,
oh,
there's no fucking way.
Like this is.
This is a crazy matchup.
Like whatsapp Petrocelli.
Ellie fought Kimbo.
Yeah.
I made a video of it.
I was in a green room in Atlanta and we
were about to watch the fight and I
thought it was Ken shamrock and
literally right before the fight I got
off stage.
I'm like,
it's about to happen right now and I can
chat box out.
I go,
he's out.
who's fighting?
And they go,
set petrus.
I go,
oh no,
sets going to kill him.
Like Steph Petros.
Ellie is legit.
The people in the know knew how that
fight was.
Yeah,
but the people that fucking crazy people
over at CBS who said yes to that or
whatever.
Was it CBS,
CBS at the time.
I like,
who do you have?
Anybody that knows mma.
That's a mismatch.
That's a gross mismatch.
You and I know the disconnect between
the people that put mma on TV and the
people that know mma is huge.
It can be,
can be,
can be huge network people.
The people that put him on tv don't
always know a man.
It crops up a lot
because you and I essentially we sort of
established positions in the sport doing
commentary like as it grew and it became
this thing that it is now.
While we know when we both started out,
I mean you go back to six years ago,
it was not nearly as big as it is now.
It's bananas how big it is now and it
sort of happened.
I guess it was really.
If you want to break it down,
and it actually happened around eight
years ago,
right?
Ultimate fighter.
That was really the biggie eight years
ago.
Was it 2004 to their,
whatever,
whatever it is,
that area in that area from there that
started this,
but like the,
the level that it's at right now,
like the fame of a GSP or an Anderson
Silva,
Jon Jones,
like,
that's,
they're right up there with basically
any athlete in pro sports.
The top level guys like they're talked
about on a,
in bars and in the same way people talk
about plays and games.
They talk about GSP,
you know,
landing at giant knee or something like
that.
It's uh,
it's,
it's interesting how this has happened.
And while while tapping.
I mean we essentially just had to figure
out our own way through it,
you know,
and learning like what's the best rules
and it seeing the rules change and
think.
Like when I first started there was bare
knuckle and you can wear shoes.
I,
that was UFC 12,
that was the first UFC I ever did
commentary on.
I did a post fight interviews rather and
uh,
to so to see it from there,
go to where it is now with flyweights
and bantams and feathers and lightweight
cement.
There's a lot of lightweight guys now.
The first time I fought was that a thing
called neutral grounds and central
grounds and pankration pin crace.
It was kind of amateur,
but not really ms dot back in the day
when it wasn't sanctioned in California,
they literally had everybody line up and
I was next to this dude and they went,
you guys simply fighting each other.
We didn't weigh in nothing.
And we went in and we thought that was,
that was how it worked.
They use open hands,
right?
Right.
We weren't
to the stakes of the body.
We had no gloves on.
And this is how crazy I remember.
I used to be really nuts and there's a
bunch of weird rules in mma that there's
just total ignorance and from just
misconceptions about w w,
one of them is at one of them is that
downward elbow.
The downward elbow is a crazy one.
It makes no sense.
The reason why the 12 to six elbow is
illegal,
big John Mccarthy told me this,
that when they were describing the
martial arts techniques to the athletic
commissions,
the guy was one of the guys that worked
for you.
That letter commission said you can't
have them do that thing with their
elbows because I've seen that on TV and
they can break boards by Golly,
what?
What?
What would it do to a person's skull
like this guy thought for some reason
that this was in any way,
shape or form as bad as Anderson Silva
kneeing you in the head makes no sense
at all.
It makes no sense at all.
Legitimately ridiculous.
Yeah,
but it's a rule that's in place like
strictly because of ignorance and there
was so many of those in the beginning.
Nobody knew what the right thing to do
was.
They were like,
well,
you can't have mma,
and they're like,
okay,
well when if we wrestle and slap fight
like,
okay,
no sense at all,
but we're going to go with it.
That was what it was for a while.
You would have pankration fights and
pankration fights.
They would pull their hands back.
It was real.
Bas rutten was the only dude who ever
figured out how to deliver like
ridiculous.
He could knock out one of those.
Yeah,
because boss has this crazy anatomy
first voice,
these giant ass long hands and he
figured out how to pull his hands way
back,
so that is like his fingers were almost
like facing towards him.
So it's like a punch.
He's punching you with his palm.
It's.
You're not catching any of the fingers.
Nothing's absorbing.
The idea I guess,
of a slab being easier is that your
fingers are absorbing some of the impact
and your hand is moving back,
which takes away that,
but boss is hitting you with this.
He's like straight punching you with his
palm.
Do you remember the exchange when frank
shamrock went for a leg lock on him and
bosses John and Frank Smile and Adam and
laugh.
There's a problem with that.
There is a problem with your rule system
when that's happening.
Yeah.
That was ridiculous.
It was funny though.
Frank Shamrock is funny and that fight,
it developed,
and I say this all the time,
MMA now,
it developed from for good or for bad,
from a sport of martial artists to
support of athletes.
Now it's a sport of athletes that don't
necessarily like we're talking about
right before the podcast about Roy
Mcdonald,
what a bad ass he is.
The guy started mma at 14.
He didn't grow up doing kilkenny.
He didn't.
He doesn't come from martial artist
background who said,
oh,
I'll turn this into mma.
These guys just studying them and they
approach it like,
like you're saying,
the NFL or the NBA or any other big time
sport and that's come with advantages
and disadvantages.
Well,
their training,
like professional athletes right now,
there is a massive difference in your
ability to move your ability to
withstand shots,
the ability to keep your energy levels
up when you're training in the gym and
you know,
especially if you're doing just only or
only
grappling,
you can get in tremendous shape.
But in this day and age it seems like it
to beat a GSP to beat like the highest
of highest levels.
Competitors,
you got to be both.
You got to be both.
A martial artist is very technical and
you also have to put the fucking time in
that you don't want to put into that
strength and conditioning.
You got to do it.
I know nobody wants to.
Nobody wants to.
Nobody wants to do battle ropes.
You don't want to fucking her old ropes
until your body feels like it's going to
explode,
but if you don't do it,
there could be just that little less
juice that you don't have in the third
and it causes you to either get caught
or it causes your opponent to get away
from something when you caught them in
something,
but you just can't squeeze it and it
gets out of it and you're like,
fuck.
The only thing,
the only time that isn't wasted in
training is cardio training.
Let's say you spend all your time on
boxing.
Oh,
you're talking about boxing the guys a
better boxer.
You fuck yeah.
You spent that time inappropriately.
You have x number of hours in the gym.
There's no negative to being in better
shape than the other guy.
There's no nate.
We were just talking about it.
There's no negative to being in better
shape.
You can be guys that are better than you
if you can wear them out.
If that happens.
It happens all the time.
It's happened to me.
I've.
I've had guys that I usually tap like
crazy.
Then I'll go to the gym and I'll be out
of shape and I'll get dominated,
you know,
I'll get mounted and my mother fucker.
It's like I'm not in shape for it and if
you're not in shape that just.
It's a fact that you're not gonna be
able to defend.
You're not going to be able to execute
to the fullest of abilities.
The hardest part is I'm on the road 12
weeks in a row because I have 12 week
season,
so I'm literally gone.
I fly out tomorrow.
I don't get back till Friday morning,
so I'm really home on the weekends.
I said,
do you train when you're,
when you're on the road.
When I see that's the problem is,
you know,
I'm working out pitbull brothers in the
elevator.
They turn to the translator and go,
pippa wants to know if you want to roll
with him,
go to my gym.
I go to my room.
I changed that would go and I with
people brother for two hours.
I'm not in.
That kind of shaped me fight.
The next day he's speaking.
He's like,
Daniel Gracie was an ed.
Jimmy went roll with me and I'm like,
all right,
you know,
but you're not in that kind of shape.
You're in their training with animals
and I go home for days to come home.
I just don't have the time.
You know,
back when I was fine,
I was six day a week guy and that's
where these guys are and it's like I'm
fighting with guys,
you know,
world champs,
and I'm like,
oh,
these people kind of don't understand
the level of conditioning that's
required to compete in mma.
It's,
it's so taken for granted.
Unfortunately.
It's like the.
There's the aspect of the sport that has
to do with what kind of shape you're in
is so gigantic and there's levels and
some guys like a Frankie Edgar,
they never let the cardio dropoff and
every time you see them you can tell
they've been pushing it.
They've been pushing it and you build a
base,
you get like a Nick Diaz type base.
Like Nick Diaz has such a strong cardio
base because he's constantly swimming,
constantly biking,
constantly running.
His cardio is sensational and you can't
keep up.
You can't.
He will drown you if you get in a fight
like that would nick Diaz is one of
those like who
can keep up this pace fight.
He's going to go 60 percent on you,
maybe 70 percent and then you're gonna
be.
You're not gonna be able to keep up,
you know you're going to try to mix it
in with 100 percent,
but it's Chins made out of
volume.
Puncher.
There's a bobby to up Paul Williams for
the,
for the boxing fans out there.
He was a great boxer.
He recently got paralyzed an accident,
but he throw a 150 punches around 100.
It's just,
that's nick deist.
He just throws so many punches so I just
won't go away so I will not go away.
And his chin,
his iron,
it allows them.
He's very relaxed so he rolls with shit
good.
And he's never committing to a punch.
You never catch him committing on.
You never get that big counter punch
because he's right.
He's slapping.
You saw such an important point that you
can't catch him with a counter shot.
There's a dude named Michael Jai white
who's a very,
very smart dude and a great martial
artist as well.
People don't know.
You seem in movies.
You think he's not like a real martial
artist now.
He's totally legit.
He's going to.
He's the one that joker cut a new mouth
in a.
He played
in that Tyson documentary,
but anyway,
my point is he was explaining like dude
is a lifelong martial artists and he was
explaining to Kimbo Kimbo we're talking
about throwing jabs and throwing punches
from just a relaxed position and that
when when someone does that,
you don't even see it comment.
It just,
it just lands and they were like going
over this,
like something that that's something
that a lot of people don't realize.
When you tense up and you're like,
telegraph,
you're gonna your chances of hitting the
guy are significantly lower than if you
just hit him.
He hit him like that and it got like
Nick Diaz is not training.
It's not full blast.
It's mechanical.
It's like tap,
tap,
pap pap,
pap pap.
It's mechanical and you starting to see
stars and then you'll step back and
like,
I'm going to blast this.
Do to get him off me.
No,
you're not.
you're going to try to,
but then you going to wear yourself out
with that big explosion that you can't
keep up with and he's going to keep 60
percent of your pap pap pap pap.
What people don't understand is there's
x amount of training sessions you can go
through in your career.
There are x amount of hours.
You can train their x amount of punches.
You can throw how you spend that energy
defines how you are as a fighter.
Yeah.
Nick Diaz is not a knockout punch,
never been knockout punches.
He throws so many that you're eventually
done.
He'll up.
He dropped Robbie lawler drop with
Jacksons you.
It was just sort of fade away.
Jose Fadeaway Jab that Robbie lawler
step right into [inaudible].
That frustration.
That's what he does too.
He unloads until you're just like,
you get frustrated,
you do something stupid and that's when
he takes you out.
You have fight to was all of the classic
shit talk and fights.
Oh,
that was awesome because that was one of
the first.
He kept doing it.
See Nick
get he got into the octagon and as he
got into the octagon,
he looks over at robby law and he's got
his arms out.
He goes,
Stockton motherfucker.
And he starts pacing back and forth and
you can see Robbie lawler is like,
what is going on here?
Like Nick Diaz claiming the two,
oh,
nine.
And walk out with his arms out.
And then he proceeded to just talk mad
shit through the whole fight.
And you could tell Robbie lawler was
like,
why?
It's,
you know,
it's funny.
I should I call me to break down the
last.
The Da has been Henderson fight.
His brother Nate took similar fighting
style course and he said,
what do you think of all that?
That Nate Diaz come get me,
you know,
all the,
the MCGINN and throwing her hands up in
the shit talking.
Uh,
their footwork isn't great.
And what it did is he's brings you into
that zone with the Mcginn and to come on
in.
And the thing is,
is that when you saw that,
saw that same problem,
uh,
with,
with nick,
against Carlos Condit,
if you don't engage him,
his footwork isn't great.
He's a little flat foot and he throws
his punches and a lot of that and come
on,
come get me,
is come into my range,
come into my kind of fight,
you know what I mean?
And that's,
it's very calculated what it Robbie do.
He stepped in eight,
really a jab hook,
not,
not a super hard punishment,
stepped right into it,
boom and went face down on the mat.
And that's part of the strategy.
Interesting about the Carlos condit
fight with Carlos condit fight.
Very similar to the way he throws his
techniques,
but he just did it moving away and
picked his own spots,
picked his own bots and moved away.
But like,
like when he landed that head kick,
you could tell just by the way,
landed.
That is not a full blast head kick.
He just thrown it up there quick to land
it,
just because he can,
if he does it that way,
it really took a page out of Nick's book
and I totally think it is.
Yeah,
I totally think it is.
I think a lot of guys,
I mean,
you think you have to,
to deal with that style because the
fucking guy doesn't get tired.
It doesn't get tired.
It takes a tremendous shot.
That's a bad combination.
You know,
like Kj noons was able to cut,
um,
and that was successful in that way,
but you know,
but then nick outboxed him in the
rematch,
you know,
the only one to really outboxed him.
Joel rigs,
diesel rigs up possibly land a little
bit harder.
Just I think landed with a little more
forced.
Remember,
you want a decision against nick in the
UFC.
What about Jeremy Jackson?
The earliest.
Jeremy Jackson,
way back in the Janet Jackson is a waste
of talent.
Man.
Jeremy Jackson was a real waste of
talent.
Unfortunately,
their kid had whatever issues,
you know,
he got kicked off of the ultimate
fighter,
I believe,
and he's got some really big legal
problems now he's in prison.
It doesn't get a lot bigger than doing
life.
I don't know what he did.
I don't know what the crime was,
what he was accused of and whether or
not he actually did it,
but I physically.
That dude,
he was a great boxer.
To this day,
he's the only guy to stop,
uh,
Nick Diaz because besides the Kj noon
cut,
which is just the doctor saying that
it's the cuts too bad.
It wasn't like that.
He was in danger.
It was just,
he couldn't see blood was pouring into
his eyes and it just looks really
grizzly.
But Jeremy Jackson stopped him like
legitimate.
And Nick was really young at the time.
It was,
you know,
I think he was only 18.
Yeah,
it was a right hand over the jab.
Yeah.
That low jab and he hadn't quite learned
to keep that hand up and use and volume
punch guest who's coming in eight a
right hand over the top and just stunned
him.
And that was it.
He had some hands,
man.
He had some hands when there wasn't.
There wasn't that much in the UFC in
terms of like,
he was like,
he had like Jens pulver type knockout
power.
Yeah.
It was sad to see that guy.
It's like he came along and mma just a
little too early and to have the main,
the endurance to get from the uh,
Nick Diaz,
you know,
18 year old stage where mma was then to
get to be like a pro today.
A few few guys.
Nobody.
Few guys.
Josh Barnett Barnett.
Yeah.
Josh is a rare,
rare example of a guy who's been in the
game a long fucking time and still
competes at the top level.
The thing that rob lava number one,
19 to 29,
you know,
the thing is you have to be open to the
kind of changes that destroy athletes.
You have to be open to men.
Men,
men past six years has gone from three
to 10 as far as the talent level and the
competitive pettiness of it.
And to stay in the mix,
even to stay in the discussion that long
is unbelievable.
You have to make the kind of cardio
commitments and training commitments
that a lot of people with that I would
say in the beginning,
martial arts mentality of this is the
way I do things.
Didn't make it.
They didn't make that transition and a
few great athletes did.
And that's why they're still around.
Yeah.
It's a weird time to see those
guys that uh,
didn't.
It didn't quite come along at the right
time.
Yeah.
You,
you only have a certain amount of time
that you can go balls out in mma and
it's,
it varies depending upon your style and
varies depending upon grappling.
I think a lot of it is really saves a
lot of guys like randy,
you know,
randy was able to continue his career
like way longer than he probably would
have if he was a pure striker,
you know,
it's the fact that he was able to,
even though he took some big shots and
some of the fights,
he was able to close the distance a lot
of the time and he's able to control
guys up against the cage a lot of the
time and that minimized like a lot of
damage that he could have taken.
It allowed him to extend his career
with,
you know,
just through the intelligence.
Look at this physical gifts that go
first.
Yeah,
speed time.
Your kids a shot.
Roy Jones Jr went off a cliff because
once you lose that,
it doesn't come back.
Well,
I think with no one's
junior are you also have to consider
neurological damage.
Oh,
severely.
Severely.
But it's one thing I hate saying that,
but if you want to be a realist,
yeah.
You have to look at the Glen Johnson
fight where he was completely out cold
and the fact that it was shortly after
the tarver fight that yet,
you know,
cleaned.
You know what got ruined him man,
when he went down in weight,
cutting weight from the fight back to
lift heavy weights.
A lot of folks don't know he won the
heavyweight title.
He fought John Ruiz and a box his
fucking face off.
It was beautiful.
It was a beautiful fight.
I mean,
you're talking about a guy won his first
title at one slash 68 and all of a
sudden he's fighting as a heavyweight
and fighting grain and there's also.
You got to question what the fuck he
took to get to be a heavyweight and when
you get off that shit,
the reality is in your body,
it stuns your body.
Your testicles stop producing
testosterone and his body looked way
smoother and the tarver fight than we
had ever seen him before.
He like depleted.
He didn't look good and he was,
you know,
he was really weak from that weight cut.
The great thing about sports,
mma,
any sport is that you see people that
are doing things that seemed beyond the
physical limits.
That's what sports is all about.
Your body will pay you back.
You cannot keep its,
you know,
cannot keep pushing that envelope and
the,
the fighters that do that,
that we see pushing them up all the
time.
There's a price to pay your body will
come back at you and,
and,
and that's just a human fact of life.
And as competent as we see so many
fighters in so many various stages of
their careers and we kind of see the
longterm in a way a lot of other people
don't because once somebody gets off a
fan's rate or they're still on our
radar,
they have to be.
That's our job.
Yeah.
Like Pedro,
his own for example.
Hey Joe,
here's a perfect example.
Okay,
you,
we saw him from knocking out Josh
Barnett,
which by the way,
new MMA fans who haven't seen that
fight,
get it on youtube.
Watch that fight.
When he knocked out Josh Barnett,
amazing.
First Time everybody knows I get to the
end of his career,
everybody knows I get a boner for leg
kicks.
The kid,
that guy,
I've never been like,
I've never felt pain through another
guy.
Feeling pain the way you do when Pedro,
his own leg.
Take somebody because your whole body
tightens up like you hear that thud.
You Go,
oh my God,
he kicked so fucking hard.
The hardest leg kicks I've ever seen in
MMA.
He had him limping
ready for Rehab for six months,
for six months.
He had to rehabilitate his leg.
He rehabbed leg kicked injuries for six
fucking months.
That's how hard pedro.
Here's a fucks your legs out a fight and
he creates these weird welts like for
the rest of your life,
you're going to have these weird like
vein welts where your veins like you
ever seen like randy has those.
And uh,
Kevin Randleman has those.
He has a lot of Moitai guys.
Get those to those weird.
That's from like just severe punishment
over and over again to your leg.
You developed these weeds.
The wall of the vein start,
start giving out from getting hit.
Oh Geez,
I called North Hollywood Moitai,
which was Ramallah pet and guys like
that with train was all tied there and
it was amazing training and yeah,
the guy,
all the traders walk around like that
and they had their shins are like steel.
I mean they were literally like,
like iron.
So they don't feel their shins anymore
because you,
you,
you hit the skin so much that it becomes
like a knuckle.
It's like,
it's weird.
Like those guys had been doing it their
whole life.
They literally don't feel shit like
regularly people kick ropes that they
wrap around like a poll.
They just thought the leg into the rope
over and over again just to deaden it.
So that becomes like a weapon and that
shit is slamming into the meat of your
fucking thigh.
Ugh.
The thing is,
and I tell marshal people into various
combat sports,
I go,
MMA is like,
I call it the dark side of martial arts
or combat sports,
quicker,
easier,
more seductive.
Those guys have more in Thailand.
200 fights.
You have your first one or two fights
for anybody knows if you are.
It's dead serious.
Hundred.
One hundred.
200 fights.
Okay.
Sandra.
I saw kickstarters like 240 fights,
30 laws where the hell it is and people
that don't understand the culture will
never be able to wrap their head around
the way they do.
They fight at a very young age and they
take on the last name of their gym.
It's almost like a slavery sort of a
situation like they own.
You Baucau had big problems with his
gym.
Yeah,
I understood.
He recently left.
Right.
And isn't that,
is that the.
Is his name or is it.
I think it was Jim's name.
That's the name.
Yeah.
Bull cow is his actual actual net,
if I'm not mistaken.
They take on the and it's a weird thing,
but those guys,
they know they take the first round off
essentially first and the fifth verse.
Yeah.
If you go to Thailand the first round I
saw a great fight.
It wasn't great.
It was fun.
Uh,
in Thailand a Turkish dude was fighting
a tiger and I was like one 60,
which is a heavyweight in Thailand,
and the first round the target,
just feeling them out,
not really throwing anything.
And the Turkish guys going,
this guy is scared or something.
He thought he was scared and kind of
went after him,
talked to just defending whatever.
And he thought he was kicking ass.
Second round the tag I opened up on him,
crushed his leg.
They stopped the fight.
Second round,
they take the first round off,
they fight rounds two,
three and four,
and then the fifth round they take off
because they know who won already.
And I was asking my instructor go,
why are they just walking around and go,
well,
they already know who won and they fight
next week.
He goes,
he fight next week.
So it's like,
okay,
you win.
And why it was weird like as an American
mentality is,
you know,
last round fucking I'm behind you go
crazy.
Yeah,
they don't really do that.
They fight rounds two,
three,
and four,
and then fifth round they take off
because he already won.
I got to fight in 10 days.
When your career is 255,
one last and hold.
It's so fascinating that literally one
style figured out how like what is the
most effective?
What is the most economic use of your
physical tools when it comes to striking
and there's one group of people in this
one small chain of islands when it was
Thailand's a couple islands,
right?
Yeah.
If you consider put cat island,
his apartment.
Yeah.
These motherfuckers figured out how to
do it.
Kick the shit out of your legs,
elbow you in the face flying knees and
it's like,
man,
you know,
if you don't know that stuff,
all the other stuff becomes invalid.
When it comes to stand up,
do you need all the other stuff?
But if you don't understand those leg
kicks,
if you don't know how to check them,
if you don't,
especially if you get a pedro,
his type dude hitting you,
you don't.
There's guys that can hit you over and
over again in the legs and you can take
it and you can have,
you know,
they can hit you like 20 times and
you'll still be moving around the end of
the fight,
but then this pedro,
his who was a couple of those,
you hear that,
hear that meat cutting shin.
Just dig into the dudes thigh and you
see the look in his eyes and you go,
oh Lord,
they've got so many of the misery of
fighting guy like that,
which I had to do in Thailand a couple
times is it doesn't knock you out.
Please knock me out.
I can go down onto the fight.
So you're standing there in it.
You either quit or you keep going,
you.
That's it.
That's your choice.
When the kicks you like
that is,
I can either quit because this sucks or
I can keep going.
It's not like a knockout.
We're like bang,
canvas and it's over.
Have you ever been stopped from?
Never.
It sucks.
I mean,
I've had trouble walking the next day,
but I never quit because of it.
You know who's going to hit you so fuck,
oh God.
It's horrible.
It's horrible and it's such an easy.
It's like an economic movement.
You know the movement of the Thai leg
kick.
It's not something that requires a great
amount of strength like a wheel kick or
spinning back kick.
It doesn't require a lot of dexterity.
It's natural for the average human
being.
That's one of the cool things about it.
It's like if you understand the
technique involved in more time,
what ties,
so prizing really technical and you can
see a lot of guys who are not athletic
specimens but they excel at it because
their technique is so good.
They know what to do when this happens.
They know what to do with that happens.
They've gone through it so many times in
the gym,
they throw that left hook of your red
legs there,
that right leg kicks comment and then
the jabs falling behind it and these
combinations,
he's classic combinations.
They start to get through,
so even like a guy who's more athletic
can't fuck with a guy who's more
technical and more time,
more so even than boxing.
Boxing,
when you shut it down to just two things
left hand,
right hand and all the combinations that
you could step man,
it's super athletic guy like a Roy Jones
Jr is always going to be the slow,
cumbersome guy.
Yeah.
The thing about a Thai kick in,
and I've been hit with every kind of
kick.
Don't fight questions,
stuff like that.
Um,
it's not hard to see.
There are only really three targets.
They hit your leg to hit your ribs to
hit your head,
but it doesn't matter if you get
something there.
All right.
I see them hit for my ribs and you block
it.
They don't care.
They'll throw one at your elbow.
I saw Andy Sour fight,
Yeltsin cloudfare texts.
You know anything about Moitai.
That's an amazing matchup.
By the end,
Andy sours arm was like bright purple
and swollen because he kept blocking me
and blocking it.
He don't put your elbow,
the throat,
your Shin.
They don't care.
When you have a guy who hits really hard
and you hold the pads for him,
how much fucking hurts?
That shit hurts.
Imagine it hitting the outside Midi soft
part of your arm with no pads.
You know a guy like Peter efforts.
Now one of those you're going to take,
you're going to take three,
you're going to take four and then
you're gonna want to cry for a month and
your whole body is going to be all
fucked up.
You just can't take those.
It's not a sport where you can say,
I'm going to train really hard and be
okay tomorrow.
No,
you don't.
You just have to extend.
I've done it in Holland and in Thailand
and was like,
it sucked.
You just have to know that this is what
I'm going to go through.
Jerome Le Banner,
one of the greatest of all time,
number one,
a k one championship,
but he was on his way and Nesto who's
banner was winning the fight and the
nested who's kept kicking his fucking
arm,
just kicked him in the arm to his arm
broke and then you see the banner go
down and tried to get back up and try to
get back into.
Then who's kicked him right in the same
fucking spot again.
Like bitch,
sorry,
slammed right into that broken arm.
He lost a fight from broken arm at the
highest level of the game.
So that's,
you have to always be worried about
taking those shots.
Your power kicker.
In terms of MMA,
the mentality is you can go through a
wrestling tournament and probably be
okay at the end if someone said,
hey Joe Rogan and Jimmy Smith,
you guys are going to grapple each other
for an hour.
We can do it.
Yeah,
we can do it.
Fine.
You know what I'm in shape or not.
Yeah.
We're not in shape and do it anyway.
Yeah,
you can take breaks.
You have to survive more time for an
hour.
No.
Yeah.
Is Hell.
And it's that mentality of you have to
learn to get through that kind of shit
to be a good mixed martial artists and a
lot of guys can't do it.
And that's the stopping point for a lot
of guys and the elbows are just starting
to make their way over the really good
elbow specialist.
So just start like Anderson has always
been a master.
Yeah.
Especially in the clench.
He's a master,
the dirty boxing elbow like he,
he'll,
he'll pull you aside with one hand.
Anderson is so surprisingly physically
strong and we saw that in like the rich
Franklin fight,
which frankly is a fucking stud,
you know,
and an Anderson got that plum on them.
It just started manipulating its neck
and driving those knees and you're like,
he's fucking strong and the technique is
perfect.
His positioning of you is perfect every
time he knows what he's doing and he
would,
he would land like a lot.
I'm only techniques,
but as far as like the high end
athletes,
you know,
they all I'm sure capable of throwing
it,
but who's been super successful with
standing elbows,
it's only like a few guys did with the
Waza was good back in the day.
Especially on like it was known for
that.
Yeah,
he would slice part.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he was,
he would let them fly.
He would have like these fucking really
wide elbows when he would come in.
I mean he was throwing torque into that.
He did a lot of spinning techniques to
that famous knock out of Charles
McCarthy with a spinning back kick.
He was one of the first.
Louisa was one of the first guys to drop
a guy with a spinning back kick.
That's way before,
you know,
Dennis seaver.
He's become like sort of the specialists
for it,
you know,
it's uh,
it's,
it's interesting to have seen that man
seeing that this sort of interesting
progression of techniques and they're
like,
just fact that front kicks to the face
of just started knocking people out in
like,
was it 2011 the need to be tore out?
I was like,
how did it make it to 2011?
That's doesn't even make,
it's such a good technique.
They're almost,
you know,
the pendulum swings around and mma,
it always has an.
And a lot of those,
if you want to say traditional martial
arts techniques we didn't see for awhile
are starting to make a comeback in mma
partly because of Anderson Silva and
stuff like that.
You know what I mean?
He's making them.
He was saying how it can be effective in
small doses.
Yeah,
have it in your back pocket for when you
need it.
It's real effective.
Well,
the whole key is they only work if you
have all the other stuff.
The problem is most of the like
taekwondo guys,
they don't have all the other stuff.
They don't have.
They don't know what leg kicks are or
they don't get.
They're not used to them.
They don't know how to sprawl.
They don't know how to grapple.
So those techniques are never going to
work.
You're not going to get them off,
so because God is going to grab you and
he's going to take you down.
But if you know all the other shit,
you know how to sprawl.
Oh Yay.
I wrestled in college.
Oh,
okay.
Do you know submission defense?
Yeah,
I'm a black belt in Jujitsu.
Oh,
okay.
And then you go,
Well how long you been doing taekwondo?
I started when I was a little kid.
I was like five years old.
And you know,
you talk about a guy who fought or like
karate style and then learn Jujitsu.
Those guys are going to have like this
weird advantage because they have this
dexterity know that the average person
just doesn't possess like a guy like Leo
Machida can kick you in the face in a
way that the average person just can't
do it because he's been doing karate his
whole life.
Like Anderson too.
Like he had a taekwondo background first
and then learned,
you know?
Yeah.
So he,
he has this dexterity with his body,
like he can do shit comfortable from
both sentences,
which is taekwondo thing.
Yeah.
Because you're going to allocate like
what you were saying before about
allocating time to training,
you're probably not going to put a lot
of time on the wheel kick.
You're about to have a fight.
Yeah.
You have to learn that shit sort of as a
child or as a straight taekwondo or
karate competitor first,
because the only way to really pull that
off is if a guy's not kicking your leg
or if a guy you know is not going to
shoot it and then take you down.
Like for you to get good at that.
When you're a white belt,
you're going to try and it's gonna be
way easier for people to take you down.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like,
it's way easier for them to take you
down and it's for you to land this
outlandish move where you're twisting
your body around like a fucking
ballerina and they're going to drop it.
You're gonna that's gonna.
You gonna throw it away,
but if you start out in taekwondo and
develop those techniques,
when that's what everybody's doing,
then you have them and then you can
learn the other things as well.
It's kind of,
it's kind of ironic that that's like a
big sport for little kids like taekwondo
is,
but I think it's okay.
Good one.
It is a good one for this.
I think so.
You know,
it's like MMA is basically a scaled down
version of these different styles of
wrestling.
You see millie different throws outside
ankle picks and stuff.
You just don't see an MMA because
they're not in that kind of range,
but they have those things and
occasionally with good guy you see it.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well,
it's,
it's always fascinating to me when a
really good wrestler gets in there and
you see guys who,
you know,
generally exhibit fairly decent takedown
defense,
just get fucked up over and over again,
like,
like junior versus Cain in the rematch.
Right.
Who was the perfect example?
So Juniors takedown defense was the best
in the business.
He had been on his back for 13 seconds
in his entire fucking UFC career and he
was the heavyweight champion.
I mean,
that's some ridiculous tap danced around
that.
But then people say,
well,
who did you fight?
That was a really good wrestler.
And you stop and you think about it and
go,
Shane,
Shane car.
When Olivia this wrestling thing,
this kid gets down and the fucking
lights land on him,
man,
that is just awful.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
And you're in parterre positions.
You're like thinking about what you're
going to do and then sucks.
How heavy is that light to that fucking
had to really hurt.
All right,
don't play it over at Madison Square
Garden.
Epic Fail on Youtube.
Oh Wow.
Everybody looked at that because it's
horrible.
Yeah,
that's fucked up.
But I think I'm listening hoodie takes
on that.
Had that kind of take down.
Nobody,
Shane.
But Shane,
I know for a fact came into that fight
injured Janet.
Janie had been having a lot of back and
neck.
Yeah.
And
he came into that fight after he had
gotten off of surgery.
I think.
Yes,
some sort of crazy spine surgery or
something like that.
I don't remember exactly what it was,
but I know he didn't have much time to
train.
I know he didn't have much time to do
any sparring,
you know,
just he's been,
uh,
he's dealing with some football injuries
from way back when.
And it's hard for that dude to get
through a solid camp without getting
hurt.
But he,
um,
like if you go back to like when I think
his best performance was Frank Mir,
that was the scariest Shane Carlin
performance.
He just murdered Frank Mir.
He got ahold of just mugged him.
He,
he had,
he had them.
He had them ran out of gas.
Yeah.
Well he fucked up.
You didn't breathe.
He was like throwing punches and not
breathing.
And then he just had nothing left.
It's too bad because if he had just
learned how to relax and pick his shots,
he might've been able to stop them in
the first round,
first of all.
And he definitely wouldn't have gassed
out like he did.
It was,
I don't know,
it's a to visit adrenaline to.
You're fighting for the title and you
just get this mad adrenaline dump and
then you realize the god is still there
and you're like,
Jesus Christ,
I might actually have to go through
three more fucking around for more
rounds of this.
Nobody listened to.
Man.
I'm serious.
If you are a,
an aspiring fighter,
if I have one piece of advice to give
you based on what Joe here right now,
never ever set a pace.
You can't keep up.
Don't throw.
If you have,
you have x number of punches and around
or you have x number of punches in a
fight.
If it's $300,
don't feel 300 punches in the first
round.
I see guys who was ultimately set a pace
and you will look.
You can't keep this up,
but you're hoping the other guy will
hopefully the other guy wants,
which is never a solid bet
ever.
It's not intelligent.
It's not an intelligent way to approach.
It can be successful occasionally.
For a guy like vandelay Silva could be
successful for fucking ever.
You know,
it was successful because he was so
murderous in his approach.
They just freak people out and then he
would stomp them and destroy them and
then people figured out,
wait,
I can throw a left hook in the middle of
this will drop your ass.
Which happened.
Cro Cop really sort of exposed that.
The difference between a real high level
striker and a guy was wild murderers
brawler angled off into,
but vandelays stills one of my favorites
of all time.
His fights were the most exciting.
Nobody was fight like if you were going
to go see a vandelay Silva fight.
That shit was an event with vandelay
fought soccer.
Abiola go,
whoa,
Jesus.
Looking at him across the corners,
doing this shit was collarbone.
We broke his collarbone three inches,
my my favorite and one was that
knockout.
The fade away.
Punch that he landed as he was stepping
forward.
And the sock Robert just flew backwards.
Man.
He is first.
I would.
Dan Henderson.
Yeah.
He put down through the floor.
Fifteen minutes.
It was a tough fight and his face was
all fucked up to it.
You only had one eye.
He could not see a lot of his left eye.
And if you want it to look at swollen I
Anderson or a vandelay Silva maybe.
You know the Google image sent?
Yeah.
Off the first.
Dan Henderson fight was one of the worst
cuts and swollen eyes I've ever seen a
guy keep fighting with.
Yeah.
It was fucking nasty.
You know,
Dan had him hurt too bad.
Took them down and then the got up.
Well Dan took
that fight on short notice those,
the thing about trading with Dan at that
time.
What are you really,
you know,
I was at team punishment at Huntington
beach and Dan,
I don't know if he lived there at the
time or lived near there.
Him and randy couture come in there all
the time and that was one of the fights
that I,
I,
uh,
was training with him for.
Dan has always had that retarded power,
just ridiculous.
And his strength.
We grappled with room.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Was grappled with a fire hydrant.
He's a man.
He's made of wood.
It's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous that I grabbed a once in
a.
I actually had a cold.
It sucked,
but he,
he mauled me.
He got me a leg lock or something like
that maybe.
And maybe it got me in a head and arm
choke or something like that.
But he was a,
he's like a dense dude dude.
Like he's like dense,
like a hold on.
Don't be like,
oh fuck,
it's got that grapplers bill,
you know,
there's a lot of dudes out there that
you don't realize how you can look at
them and they develop this like freak
grapplers strength.
Yeah.
You know,
from just years and years and years of
throwing bodies around what Dan has done
that a lot of people don't as he's
adapted that to striking.
You can't turn that into a knockout
power.
In fact,
it's hard because they're used to being
such varied as they can't get that snap
in there punches.
Dan has somehow translated that grappler
body into a knockout punch,
which a lot of guys can't do.
Yeah,
and typically it wasn't the Greco guys
that would get like really good at
striking either.
Right now I'm just more of the freestyle
guys because the freestyle guys could
shoot and when you're.
When you develop that sort of ability to
explode in a double leg,
that shit.
Same Shit can come with a punch.
Like Kevin random is a perfect example.
He had the retard,
just unbelievably fast powered devil and
Kevin randleman his prime.
He was a steamroller.
He would just freight train your ass.
I mean he was and he,
he could jump over your body like he,
he.
So he was so ridiculously athletic.
He could jump over your fucking body,
you know,
and random.
And when he would land a punch,
he could land a punch the same way.
He could land that double.
He would explode on you before you even
know it was common.
And you can crack you and tag you.
And that's what he did to cro.
Cop,
he knocked out Cro,
cop.
That was like a crazy surprise.
Then you know,
it wasn't a surprise that he had one
you,
if you took them down and you know,
mold them on the ground,
knocked about the fact that he knocked
them out with like,
I think it was a left hook.
Just ridiculous speed.
And that coming from that,
you know,
that use of that wrestling background.
But it's a weird thing to transition
from a sport where you don't ever get
hit to transition from a sport where you
very might likely get knocked
unconscious.
At least in practice.
It's very likely one day you're going to
get unconscious wrestlers.
What they bring generally to mma is
they're incredibly hard workers.
It's just.
And I wrestled in high school and it was
just,
it's incredibly difficult to training
and they compete a lot.
It can be a lot,
lot of tournaments,
you know,
a,
a wrestler in the NCAAS by like 40,
40 matches in a year.
They reached out to because of the
fucking weight cutting.
They're just used to companion that used
to cut and wait.
There used to be a miserable,
miserable and hungry and all the time.
So it's not a big deal.
The problem they have is they have to
adjust to getting hit and you know,
there are certain wrestlers that,
that,
that never make that successful mental
leap.
There's also an issue with
overtraining and that's a real issue
with wrestlers and you know,
it's like this whole willingness to push
it farther than the next man and the
pain is just weakness.
Leaving your body.
That's all well and good,
but the reality is you should probably
be paying attention to your heart rate.
You should probably know.
Is it up five beats today from
yesterday?
Yeah.
Well,
you're overtraining.
Do you want.
Why don't you piss in a cup?
Oh,
you're dehydrated.
It.
Look what's going on here,
dude.
You don't have minerals in your body.
Know,
like the wrestling mentality is like,
shut up pussy,
get up,
put on your fucking converse all stars
or run up hill to get in there,
get in there and that,
that's good and it's bad.
It's good if you're,
you're,
you know,
you're super honest about what's going
on but bad if you know you're not and
you don't pay attention to signs of over
our wold in wrestling before mma,
when resident is wrestling,
how old did people wrestle?
You didn't get out of your mid twenties
generally speaking,
so you can have that mentality because
you only did it.
You 25 problems.
You take that to mma where you could do
it until your mid thirties.
Randy couture to 40.
You can't maintain that.
How about Hopkins man?
Oh my God.
How to explain that?
You know what it is.
I'm going to tell you why I'm gonna.
Tell you why the dude is tech.
I've never seen him get hurt.
I've seen,
I don't know how many Bernard Hopkins
fight since way back in the day.
His first fight with Roy Jones.
Okay.
The guy doesn't get is technically so
good that he hasn't gone through the
things physically.
A lot of fighters have gone through.
He hasn't.
Did Chad Dawson drop him?
I don't think Chad doesn't ever dry.
I didn't see the fight.
I don't think ever dropped him unless
I'm mistaken.
I don't think that number's dropped him
off at work though.
I mean it's easy to do when you're 45
and it is what it said.
There's 48 dudes.
She's 48.
Then this fighting soon.
I think he's fighting in March.
There's something I want to talk to you
about.
I want to ask you.
Okay.
As a commentator,
because we.
We interview thousands of fighters.
Thousand.
Yeah.
There's something called the heartmath,
which is in interviews.
We asked a fighter,
you know,
I've had fighters cry.
They wanted something so badly.
I want this so bad.
They literally cry.
They literally break down in front of
us.
They go in there,
they take on a guy who's just better
than they are and they lose.
Yep.
I was at Ego Wagner Jujitsu down in
Missouri.
I was picking up a car and I just like,
hey,
how do we go values here?
And I was doing some Jujitsu with them
and all these guys are going to go,
what?
What?
What would you tell a guy getting ready
for mma?
And I go,
be technically sound,
will listen to your coaches and make
sure you have all the tools to win.
And they all kind of sat and they were
quiet for a second.
I went,
I thought you'd give some speech about
heart.
And I know I've seen guys with a heart
without technique makes a beating more
interesting because the guy is still
getting up when he's getting tattooed.
Absolutely.
And I go,
if you weren't technically sound like
Bernard Hopkins probably beat a lot of
guys with my heart that he had floyd
mayweather weeds.
A lot of guys with more heart than they
have because they are technically sound.
They're really sounded.
Yeah.
Heart's important.
And what?
You can't overstate the importance of
heart.
But guys who go,
yeah,
I'm tough.
I got heart.
I go,
yeah,
that can make a beating a lot more than
you need.
You don't have the technique to go with
it.
And it brought.
Hopkins is a great example of that,
of a guy who is just technically really,
really sound.
It had a long,
great career because of it.
You know?
I mean,
people think that somehow my heart's
going to overcome a guy who put in more
work and it's more tech than I am and it
it.
It rarely works.
It works often enough that it's
developed this myth of that that you
cannot work these guys and you know,
if he's in shaping as good technique,
that is really,
really hard to do and it's something
I've noticed over and over again and
fighting the guy can be motivated as
shit.
If you didn't have the technique and you
didn't put in work,
it is not going to help you.
Yeah,
it'll happen.
I'm now and then if you catch a guy
who's out of shape or a guy who's got it
and weakness in his game,
like a striking weakness in his game,
maybe he's,
maybe he's more technical and grappling
and you have more heart,
you'd take it to them,
but a guy was technically sound across
the board.
You're absolutely right.
It can expose the other guys.
Lack of preparedness.
That's what heart does.
It exposes the other guys lack of
preparedness because you know the first
one,
shogun forest,
the first shogun.
Forrest Shogun was not prepared for that
fight,
he just wasn't physically prepared.
And what happened in the rematch showing
was prepared and blasted for it.
So that's probably the biggest heart in
the whole game,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's one of those things where I think a
lot of people,
and you know,
it's a great story.
This guy with this big heart defeated
this guy and I said,
hey look,
guys,
be technically sound
first before anything else.
I think you're dealing with two
different us too.
There's a difference of several fights
and fights,
forest fires sites,
you know,
forrest is known for having the most
exciting fights in the UFC history.
The most important,
exciting fight in the history of the UFC
was Stephan Bonner and forrest griffin,
the files of the ultimate fighter
because we're folks who haven't seen it.
It's a real classic.
I watched it again recently because it
was just a,
I don't know what I was dealing,
but uh,
I,
I've saw was,
you know,
I have a bunch of them dvr and I've
watched that fight and I was like,
wow,
what a.
It was at the time it was so crazy,
like we knew it was going to be a good
fight,
but when they got on there and they just
went off,
that was,
it was just chaos.
There were so evenly matched.
They had trained together for so long.
They knew what the fuck each other did
and they just went after each other for
three glorious rounds.
Maybe made him in that modern man.
He can't do that forever,
you know,
that's not the smartest way to fight.
The smartest way to fight is to be
technical and to choose your spots.
And although I appreciate for sure from
a point of view of like a spectator who
loves to say,
you know,
I,
I appreciate the fuck out of the fact
that they did it,
you know,
and it was great to watch.
Well pay to watch that guy anytime,
anytime,
anytime.
Yeah.
Chris leave and is always going to be a.
But I think Chris is a not the right
example anymore because he's got a lot
more technical over.
Like especially if you go back to like
the Erin Simpson fight.
He fought very smart in that fight,
you know,
his last fight wasn't as best fight the
Derek Brunson fine,
but you know,
he's got,
you know,
just he had a,
he had at least a year off,
you know,
and he had substance issues and a bunch
of other shit going on,
so I dunno.
But Chris liebing is always one of the
most exciting guys.
He's one of those guys that he might not
ever be the champion.
You might not ever be able to beat
Anderson Silva.
I will pay to see that guy fight any day
of the week.
Anytime.
You'll know,
whatever.
Everybody forgets,
you know,
and you know,
we deal with a lot of people that don't
understand the nature of the business.
We're in the entertainment business,
sports where you are in the
entertainment business and fighters like
forrest griffin and I was like Chris
leaving and the,
the,
you know,
you know Michael Chandler for us,
the guys that go in there and just put
it on the dude and I was just a fireball
from beginning to end.
That's what,
that's what people tune in for.
The handler guy is very exciting man.
Beast.
He goes off.
I did not expect that at all.
He's an intention and being like,
you see when he's talking,
you know he's got.
He's got a lot going on behind the eyes.
You're just getting started.
That's the scary part.
Yeah,
I think so.
You know,
I was super impressed with him and Eddie
Alvarez fight.
That was,
I was sick.
Incredible.
She's done it.
Then the third round,
did you really?
I was like,
because that third round Eddie starts 10
off channel,
looked at a gas.
I was like,
okay,
this is probably great performance.
This is probably it.
He came out and round for like it was
shot out of a cannon.
Eddie just was not ready for it.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Bad Dude.
There's so few of those guys that like
have this special thing about them and
you see them come up and you go with
this guy just for whatever reason he
just stands out.
Like what percentage of it is it?
Is it,
is it one percent of all the fighters?
I mean,
what,
what is it,
what percentage that you see when you
see a guy,
Nico,
this something that this dude has that
other people just don't?
Five percent.
Yeah.
I would go as high as 55 percent use.
You and I have seen where even if it's
even just getting started,
you're like keeping it on that day.
Yeah,
because that dude's got it.
First Time I suggest put Carl prison.
I went,
alright,
this dude is going to be a problem.
I always have every sps,
early fights and I was there when he
fought a jay her on.
That's when I knew.
I was like,
wow,
this guy's fucking savage.
Savage.
But the first one that I knew,
he was good.
The one that really turned my head when
he damali frank trigg.
Yeah.
He demolished frank trigg.
You went.
He wrote,
okay.
Because trick at the time was a top
contender.
Only lost to Matt Hughes and soccer and
it was like he just balled him.
He ran through them.
He just put up a page that frank trigg,
especially when it got to the ground of.
Oh,
it's just manhandled them.
Yeah.
I think it was like really shocked.
I don't remember when he got off of a
trick said,
you're really fucking good man.
You're really fucking good.
He was just shocked.
Yeah.
There's a few of those guys,
like when Anderson first came into the
octagon and we fought Chris leaving,
I knew I had seen him fight many times.
I'd seen his difference between his
pride days where he was still learning
submissions and is more time,
wasn't exact word was then to the cage
rage days.
When you went over to England,
there's a cage rage
in cage rage.
When he fought Lee Murray and he fought.
Tony frequently hit him with that upward
elbow was a stepping forward,
upward,
elegant.
Missed.
He's like,
you pretend to miss the hook,
and then we loaded him with blam and
caught him on the Chin and knocked and
completely unconscious and I knew that
Anderson was something special.
I knew he was coming into his own,
especially the Lee Marie fight because
Lee Mary,
who went on to be one of the most
notorious criminals in UK history and
get a movie about it.
Of course,
you know,
from what I've heard MMA fighter turned,
uh,
he was alleging is Tyson because,
well,
he,
he was history at the time.
Apparently the story goes that he met
Tito Ortiz in London back when Tito was
the champ.
And uh,
he uh,
either didn't know Tito was or didn't
give a fuck who tito was and they got an
a street fight.
And the word is that Lee Marie one,
the street fight.
That was what everybody had said.
And then,
you know,
I mean,
even after Tito,
last to chuck in the post fight
interview,
who was talking about how there's 185
pounders running his mouth.
Shoot,
it was,
this is after he just thought chocolate
down and got stopped.
He was calling out Leanne Marie.
So it was a legit chief.
Something happened for sure.
And then he went from there to,
uh,
getting somehow or another involved in
this insane armed robbery,
like right out of state the movie where
they have masks on and machine guns.
And they held hostages and they stole
millions and millions of dollars.
And then one of the biggest heist in
British history,
and then he went to Morocco and then in
Morocco he got arrested for,
I think it was like cocaine and
kidnapping.
Ridiculous.
Like how many years can I add onto my
sentence here?
Let me see.
Let's take a look at it here.
You would think.
Okay,
I'm on the run from the biggest armed
robbery in the UK history.
I got this fat bag of money with me.
What do I come out?
I never understand.
And there's a great dark cooking
cowboys.
Ever seen it?
Great documentary.
Corbin Corbin,
I met that guy in,
uh,
in,
in Florida.
Great Guy.
One thing I kept thinking as I was
watching that movie,
and by the way listeners,
if you haven't seen cookie cowboys was
great documentary.
Check it out.
Amazing.
And two,
one into there's two.
And these guys make hundreds of millions
of dollars closer.
At what point do you go out,
done not risking life sentence over
this.
I have $50 million.
Can I budget in my head?
Okay.
Yeah,
I can live on this.
Well,
I think,
I don't think that you could spend the
money.
I think they take the money and it
becomes like they know what the numbers
on the money where and then they put
that in the circulation.
Be alerted to get a legit job and go,
I know I'm going to be a mortician.
We're going to have to be in Morocco to
not go to prison for the rest of my
life.
Yeah.
I would rather be lucky.
I think he gets like girls in there
because got a chick pregnant.
He's
hooked up there.
That's why.
That's why he ran there.
His family's Moroccan.
I guess they got some juice in Morocco
so I don't.
Maybe he's dealing with like the the
Pablo Escobar prison in Colombia.
That's like a compound.
I don't let them.
The idea of supporting criminals.
Neither do I,
but I do like the idea that this a place
you can go where jail's not really jail
and he could pay some people off and
just live like they did the rest of the
world,
Bro.
That is the rest of the world.
I've been all over the place.
It's the rest of the world,
man.
I don't really think that,
you know,
you should be using it in a bad way.
I don't think corruption should be used
in a bad way,
but once he used that way,
when a guy can get a dope cell because
he's paying for,
they can bring in girls.
I don't really hate it,
you know?
I mean,
look,
fucking a security guards got to do is
security guards got a tough way to make
a living,
isn't it?
So I don't mind him getting a few extra
hundred bucks if he brings it hookers.
Really Marie,
I really don't see a problem with that.
The unions in California,
it's really hilarious.
Here in California,
the prison guard union is one of most
powerful unions in California.
Every time they tried to do any kind of,
well,
can we search guards before they go in
there or something because dark guards
are making huge money,
get old cell phones and give them to the
prisoners and Melissa,
they can do their thing.
They stop it every single time,
every single time and because if they
know they're all corrupt and then all
they're all sneaking weed in and that's
okay.
The fuck man,
you know,
this needs to be a little room for
fuckery in this world.
Everything can be cigarettes.
Twenty bucks.
Let's prison.
He was in a cigarette is 20 bucks a
cigarette,
one cigarette being a guard and bringing
in a pack of cigarettes and making that
kind of money.
Yeah.
Brian would be worth every penny.
It would give you that money.
You would,
wouldn't you?
Right.
Probably just have one Sayer Ji who he'd
be one a day.
What could you deal with like $100
cigarette habit a week and you deal with
one cigarette a day or would you just go
crazy?
I probably have like two hits.
Put it out to hits the next day,
put it out so I would make it last like,
I know you're like crazy.
That's like serious addiction.
How many,
how many of you smoking a day these days
about a pack?
Are you worried about like when you hear
that our friend Duncan gets cancer,
you know,
and he's basically your age and then all
of a sudden you know,
he's going through radiation and all
this shit.
Does that freak you out at all?
I don't put cigarettes at mass or
anything.
Hey,
what are you trying to say about talking
shit about a fucking person?
You know what else?
What else is bad that I do?
You know,
I drank,
I do drugs,
I smoke whatever.
So you just don't give a fuck about your
meat vehicle.
You're just gonna ride that shit until
the wheels fall off.
Is that the idea?
Yeah.
Wow.
I guess,
yeah,
everybody's got their own decisions to
making this really hard to be a comedian
and go to a comedy club and not drink.
It's really hard to go to be a comedian
and go to a comedy club and not smoke.
It's like almost impossible.
Well,
it's more fun if you do those things.
That's the problem.
You know,
you're hanging out with comedians and
you want a drink.
Fuck it.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
You know,
pulls out a joint yet little known fact.
I've never had a drink in my life.
Really little known fact.
But my parents are both alcoholics.
Oh,
dad's real bad.
Real bad.
Good move that man.
I was like,
I don't need this.
Yeah.
Just in case.
Just in case we went back off.
That's a reason why I've never tried
cocaine.
I,
I get a chance to watch no one in my
family,
but I have chance to watch some friends
lose their fucking shit over it.
It's good.
Smart to learn.
You know,
I'm not saying that everybody should
have an alcoholic in their family,
but you should really held the broad
spectrums of how bad something can fuck
up your life.
You know,
the show intervention on any.
My,
my wife's a producer and she produced
intervention for like a year and a half.
She was,
she worked for the production unit,
didn't mention the story.
She would tell me about these addicts.
So.
And it's the what,
what's weird is the inconsistency of it
where some adults will do one drug and
it doesn't really do.
Yeah,
it's okay.
Whatever.
But,
but,
but coke is their thing or why our
systems,
our brains key into a particular drug
and go and they can't get off whatever
it is is,
you know,
it's,
it's really weird how some people are
hard hardwired for that and other people
aren't.
I don't really have an addictive
personality.
The only thing I remember,
you know,
I love fighting,
I love training,
but that's more of a reaction that you
could call it a physical addiction to
some,
to some degree,
but,
you know,
it's,
it's weird what keys into certain
people,
how some people get hooked on something
other people have no problem with it.
There's a lot of genetic variables.
Yeah.
Especially when it comes to.
I mean,
it's the oldest running,
you know,
story in America really from the dawn of
the,
uh,
the pilgrim days.
It was the Indians and their inability
to handle alcohol.
That is the American and native
Americans have consistently had a
problem with alcohol.
And the idea is that genetically they're
bodies are not designed to process it
because it wasn't a part of their
culture until the white man showed up.
So it was this massive Polynesian.
I grew up in Long Beach.
A lot of samoans.
Yes.
Last thing you want is a family of drunk
samoans.
Yeah.
You're right after you.
Right.
They love me.
I lost some old friends so I'm cool.
But man,
they roam in packs with families and
yeah.
Well I find that generally very friendly
people.
Unbelievably friendly.
Family oriented.
Yeah.
Just don't be content with you.
Yes.
But uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
cultural lack of a history with alcohol
fucks them up,
man.
It really can.
There's some.
And then there's a cultural history of
fucking straight alcoholics.
I'm like a lot of Irish folks.
Yeah.
And my dad was half Irish.
There you go.
Yeah.
I have a good buddy who's a dad,
was Irish and drunk a Greg Fitzsimmons.
He's told the story 100 times and about
how his dad,
you know,
fucking crashed a car while he was drunk
and then,
you know,
it was in the hospital for awhile and
then got out of the hospital and like
almost immediately started drinking
again.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
it doesn't.
Like my dad went through dts while
driving.
One time my mom said,
well,
he was driving,
apparently had any drink in the morning,
which is weird.
I don't know what he was thinking,
but anyway,
but mom said you were in the backseat or
you,
you know,
we were there and he started shaking and
he started shaking any,
pulled the car over and he started
convulsing and a cop came and said,
do you need help?
Does he need to go to the emergency
room?
Because he was having convulsions.
Gideon drink that morning.
One day.
One morning,
Bro.
One morning I saw he had a head injury,
which is how he will,
not really how he died,
but he had a head injury and he was in
the hospital.
One time I went to visit him and they
had him tied to the bed and he's like
thrashing around in.
His eyes are rolling back.
He's literally in a coma,
but dts we'll go through them anyway.
It doesn't.
Your body's still reacting to the fact
that you don't have any alcohol.
So these thrashing around and he's
screaming and all this stuff,
and I.
I'm looking down at him and I forget who
I'm with.
And they went,
can you believe this?
I turned them off.
That's why I don't drink.
You see it,
you wanna take a picture of this because
this is why I don't drink.
She was like,
yeah,
I can see why you don't drink this.
Your body will go through dts anyway,
whether you're in a coma or not,
you know,
so that kind of stuff,
you know.
So it's like,
what?
I just stay away from what's wrong with
people.
I don't know.
Design can get hooked on alcohol or
heroin or something that sucks.
Something that's bad for it and
something like working out.
It's been asked for people and they
don't want to do it.
Well,
you know what,
for some,
for some people,
uh,
I,
I kinda stay away from.
It can't go a couple of days without
some sort of training.
It makes me feel better.
You know,
I'm suffering through a bulging disc
right now.
And I started getting rolfing.
Rolfing though.
Thank God.
No,
I have not very painful,
but it's really amazing.
And like what kind of pain relief it
gives you once the pain is over,
like the loosening of my back,
my back feels more limber than it's felt
like a year.
Like I've had an issue with my back for
quite a while.
I could get injuries.
Neck is bad.
You have bulging.
Uh,
yeah,
I think so.
So do you,
did you get an MRI or anything?
Did you get.
No,
Scott,
this is years ago when I was at teen
punishment.
Somebody dropped me on my head and I,
I it balls.
It herniated slight herniation here.
Yeah.
And uh,
I had therapy for like six months and
they went okay,
and this is a backline how many money?
So I had to have a friend of mine as
chiropractors take care of it,
but it was like therapy and it fixed it,
but it's the one thing that I'll be
sparring.
I'll take one and I'll fill this and I
got,
I got to stop,
I keep going,
then I got to put ice on it and all that
stuff.
It's just always a slight problem.
So you do still have a bulbs?
They're probably.
Yeah,
no press in life.
Yeah.
If I get hit on the head janitor,
what happened to mark Coleman apparently
got paralyzed.
He was training with random and again
and random and dumped amount his head
and he couldn't move for like,
I think it was something crazy like 30
seconds.
Like his body was just completely
frozen.
That's a scary 30 seconds.
Oh my God.
Well he thought this is it.
I'm going to be in a wheelchair for the
rest of my life directly myself with my
mouth,
you know,
and that's,
that's what could have happened to them.
Going from the UFC heavyweight champion
of the world and that from one like that
wilkes retired because of that.
Did he?
He was the guy that I fought actually
when I was fighting.
I fought James Walks and he had a some
kind of herniation in his neck and set
and the doctor said,
if you keep doing this,
you're going to risk paralysis.
And when I'm out I'm out.
There's different ways to treat it,
you know,
I'm the Ra thing though,
was a buddy of mine from the gym had a
good personal experience from it and he
was like really painful stuff,
but when it's done,
like when they're breaking the muscle,
like the muscle Fascia,
I guess they're ripping it off the scar
tissue,
whatever they're dealing with,
their elbows.
It's fucking horrifically painful.
They put all their weight on,
but when it's done like man,
like all the sudden like there's all
this range of motion that wasn't there
before and I tried to say like,
is this fuckery man?
Is this like some,
some,
some bullshit Voodoo that they put on me
and given me a rubber place hit with a
Hologram on it and saying it's gonna
make my balance better.
But I think objectives,
no,
there's,
there's some serious relief in my.
I'm pretty consistent about like deep
tissue massage and all the different
things.
Chiropractic care,
but this made a difference.
Like it was a noticeable difference.
A fighter is always in pain.
I've never fought in a retrain.
Don't understand that like any,
any athlete or basketball players and
knees are shot.
I go,
it's,
they're constantly in pain and the
difference between hurt and injured,
his align a fighter is always walking a
fighter.
Never goes in.
Not hurt ever.
I've never seen it.
That is always in pain
thing is,
you know,
a lot of guys trained through injuries
and that's why how I fucked my backup
way worse.
It was like I injured it and then I was
like,
yeah,
just keep rolling.
I'll just go talk to them.
Call Roll Light.
I'll tap quicker,
you know,
I won't,
I won't put myself in strength.
Bullshit.
Once you get out there,
you start rolling.
Starting the whole purpose of role in.
It's try to get dudes.
They're trying to get you and you can't
try to get them.
It's not fun.
No,
you know,
so you're,
you're not going to enjoy it.
And the reason why you're doing in the
first place,
most of this because it's fun.
So you're going to go after I'm going to
get to go home.
Yeah.
I had done,
I had numbness in my hand and I would
get this pain in my elbow and things got
the Ulnar nerve is so you'll see seven
or something like that where your injury
is just here.
Yeah,
that's a really scary one.
Getting dropped on the head sucks.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons I liked that.
Jujitsu starts on the knees.
The bad thing is that a lot of guys
don't have good take downs or take down
defense and if you you face a wrestler,
you're really fucked.
If you can't take him down and he's
better standing because then you're
doomed,
you're just going to get.
You're gonna get teed off on.
It's easy to defend submissions if
you've been grappling your whole life.
It's just a natural thing for them.
It's really hard.
I hate carrying around,
but man,
getting tossed around is one of the
easiest ways to get fucking seriously
hurt when you're.
When you're wrestling with really good
guys who can throw,
you know guys who can.
They get double unders on you and they
fucking Suplex you legit in the gym
where they're launching their back,
like a fucking bridge,
you know,
and
slamming you into the ground first with
them behind you.
All 200 plus pounds of them,
you can get really fucked up like
separated shoulders.
Terrible disc injuries.
So I don't fuck with that man.
I know it's an important thing to do to
like roll with a guy like that to know
what's possible.
But the,
the worries about getting slammed on
your head.
To me that's a big one.
That's a,
that's a gigantic.
The most injuries I've ever seen in
combat sports.
Judo,
there's judo is like.
It's funny because people don't think
about it.
It's like man,
that's.
It doesn't seem like it would be the
worst.
People get thrown in their elements pop
out or nice.
Probably a fault.
I mean world champs.
Yeah.
You'll shoot a broke his arm in a
tournament because.
And that's a world champ.
Yeah.
Do you just,
you don't see that that often?
Like hardly ever will a guy,
you know?
Occasionally I'll get an arm broke,
easily tap,
but they typically don't want to tap.
When you get thrown,
you're not in shock array.
Haji gracie fight where he didn't.
Sap tucks it in his.
He'd let them fight and he let him break
his fucking arm and then he got out of
it and won by points.
I could not believe I trained machine
grab too,
but how?
What is his mentality?
He let a dude break his arm and a
Jujitsu tournament.
Where's he going?
What is he gonna win that $100,
man.
What the fuck is he going to win?
How much is it?
You just do tournament pay at 20,000.
What's.
What's it worth to get your fucking arm
salute?
Final match of the absolute sued stuffed
in there and this is after you'd already
won his division and just defended for
the last few seconds for him.
Big Deal for him,
man.
He's a beast.
Dude's a beast.
That's a.
that's a serious competitor man who lets
you break his fucking arm and just says,
fuck it.
I'm going to keep up.
Well,
here's one thing.
Here's one mentality.
Here's,
here's one thing you can say though,
is there is the idea of,
well,
fuck it,
it's already broken.
I got a minute and I remember it wasn't
a lot of time left.
Let's say a minute and a half left of a
10 minute match and he went,
it's already broken.
It's not going to get more broken.
Fuck it.
Maybe I can win this thing.
It's not the kind of thing where it's
like an MCL goes out and like if I stand
on this,
it's going to get even worse.
Fucking broken is broken on.
It ain't gonna get a whole lot worse and
when I got a minute left and made it.
Yeah.
That was the mentality of yeah,
I can't make it twice I guess,
but can.
The real problem is when a guy gets a
physical injury like that,
like you'd get an arm snapped or a nice
nap,
you might not ever be the same again and
you might have to go through Rehab for
seven months,
eight months if you're lucky.
If everything goes perfect,
if you can schedule your surgery in time
and then go through it all,
it's like,
that's why everybody's terrified of guys
like who's Mr Paul Harris,
who some are,
gets a hold of your leg and starts
rolling and he's,
I think he's my height and a foot wider
than me,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know how much weight he cuts to
get down to a hundred 85 pounds.
But he's,
he literally looks like a cartoon
figure.
He's,
he's from,
from my team.
Carlson Gracie,
you know,
he's one of them was the Montana is and
I'm with Haiti.
Yoga was you the same family and stuff.
And uh,
the dude is one of those guys where it's
like,
you are,
you.
Are you okay
to Jujitsu all you do because it's like
if you saw in Abu Dhabi and he took on
God I,
Marco's Avalon,
I want to say had him and he'll hook.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And he keeps rolling and they're like,
we're out of bounds.
And he taps and he knew that Marcos have
law was lightening up because they're at
a browns.
And then he just went for the kill and
try to submit it,
but he stood up like,
Oh,
good match,
because that one was furious.
Then remember they restarted,
they restart and when the heel hook tap
and they said,
ready go,
you can't do that.
You can't because there's a lot of
momentum and moving and you generate
that momentum to say stop,
ready,
go.
That's a big advantage to the guy that
was applying to submission you,
you allowed him to get to a superior
position because that initial explosion
is way quicker to do with your arm like
that than it is to do with your leg and
twisting your fucking foot.
That's already in a bad spot.
Ready?
Go.
But it's the idea of more because I was
clearly upset and,
and Tokyo is like,
are you paying attention?
Slapped him.
When he went to hug him,
like he hit him,
which maps.
And he jumped up on the fence before the
fight was over.
Oh,
that was Kim Miller.
Dan Miller,
Dan Miller.
It's that combination of,
you know,
sick on the ground and not all their
upstairs is frightening.
Yeah.
He's a nut frightening and he's been a
leg snapper forever.
Years.
Yeah.
He's,
if you've never seen him.
He says,
Harry guerrilla type man.
And his technique is lawless.
Yeah,
he's so strong,
but his technique is perfect.
There's a video online with him rolling
with mayhem in Brazil and he takes me.
He takes him down like smoothly passes,
um,
takes his back and then transitions to
the arm bar all in one glorious move.
And you watch them.
You Go,
God damn,
that guy's just fluid like water.
I mean,
the way he,
he,
he ducked under ma'am.
Scooped him,
dumped him,
just took his back,
took the arm by.
You're like,
well,
I know mayhem,
man.
Mayhem is no joke.
Man has a very good ground game.
He's got very good defense.
He survives a lot of shit.
And to see that guy run through them
like that,
he like,
Woo wasn't even there.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a bad motherfucker,
but no.
Plan B,
the hector lumbar fight was a terrible
matchup for him because Hector Lombard
is so fucking powerful with his hands.
And Hector's takedown defense is
ridiculous.
When you see the Tim Boetsch fight,
it wasn't a good fight for hector was
one of his worst fights ever,
but look good.
It's fucking takedown defense is.
I mean,
he sprawls and slammed down to the
ground with them.
That is a power sprawl.
When he gets those,
you know,
when Bush shot in on him and he,
he,
he over under them and kicked his hips
back and drop the two of them down to
the ground.
You're like,
whoa.
That is some other worldly strength.
That's another dude.
He's like five foot nothing and like
feet wide.
He's
like five,
seven,
five,
eight and just built like a fucking
comic book hero and his,
his movement,
like the shit that he's,
that he can do to people,
you know,
it's striking the put on people.
He's just a ridiculous,
ridiculous athletic specimen.
Josh Barnett said that a heat taught him
muscle ups,
you know,
that he had never done it before,
which a muscle up is.
You start with a chin up and then you
pull yourself up to your Chin and then
you push yourself all the way up to like
a dip.
So you're fully extended and he said
like,
it's hard to do.
Like Alistair Overeem,
they liked,
someone was trying to,
they had one of those gymnastics do,
it's like street,
you know,
let's treat workout dudes that do a lot
of like crazy core strength,
athletic moves and he couldn't do it,
helped along by just starts whipping
them off.
Bam,
Bam.
Just does like 10 muscle ups in a row,
which is impossible to,
to never have done it before.
And just pull yourself up like that over
and over again.
You got to be unbelievably strong.
I've had people tell me that when he was
at CSW,
which is Josh,
Brian's team here in southern
California,
uh,
on Fulton.
They were like,
mop up the blood when they would spar.
Oh yes.
Hector does not know how to spar.
Luckily he doesn't know how to be like,
he just goes full out all the time.
Just Barnett.
Gigantic dude.
Well,
there's a legendary story of Josh
Barnett,
like punishing him or he got on he
mounted and they would not let them go
and just kept beating them up because
apparently there was an issue with
hector beating up other people in the
gym.
If you're sparring hector,
that's always been the knock is that
he's going to fight you like you're
fighting.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So God damn competitive.
And he's so fucking good.
He just needs to destroy all the time.
He's like,
this is fucking destruction machine,
you know?
And,
and it,
you know,
he even talks about it in post fight
interviews,
one of the posts.
But you know,
my trainers say you have to be nicer.
You know,
I can't have toys to play with.
You break your toys,
you can play with bro Bro.
That's what it is,
bro.
Dudes,
he's a,
he's a scary guy.
He is.
But I'm glad he's back on track.
That is,
if I put it back on track,
certainly so many exciting fights for
him.
You know,
there's a,
the thing about having only two
promotions,
it's like,
I mean there's other like small feeder
promotions that go,
well,
it's a national promotion.
It's belt on UFC.
That's it.
That's all there is now.
I mean,
especially now that strikeforce has
done,
but there's so many guys.
They go,
damn,
I want to see that guy over there.
Like,
Oh yeah,
I would love to see Chandler fight
Benson.
I think that would be fucking test.
I would love that fight.
I would love to see pet current fight
basically any 145 pounder in the world.
I a great against pimples,
great graphite and he's another one were
really follows the principles of being
technically sound really tight,
tight,
tight and not.
It doesn't open.
Exposed himself,
doesn't go emotionally.
It doesn't do anything crazy but mixes
things up really good.
Like between punches and knees that you
don't see.
Comment and kicks.
You don't see common.
No.
Wind up with the kicks,
you know?
It's throwing a lot of kicks,
karate style that are getting when you
don't expect him to.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He's very good.
Sandro fight,
dude,
when you kicked him,
I was like,
oh,
done.
I could not.
I did not say that.
Come on.
Yes.
Sandra was a beast standing too.
He's a dangerous fucking strike or
knocked him dead.
He's very,
very,
very good.
There's,
there's a few of those guys,
you know that or I see and I go,
damn,
I wish I could get that guy in the UFC.
I get to see my Melatonin.
I'm sure.
Well,
I hope that eventually they figure out
some way where you know,
there can be,
you know,
like if it comes to a point where
there's some bellatore heavyweight that
is just the shit and just destroying
people.
It's all over television.
If it gets to a point,
but ideally it would be great if there
was like equal value because if it was
equal value then everybody would get
together and said,
listen,
we've got to promote.
Let's fucking make a deal.
Come on.
What do we do in here?
This is crazy.
Let's chop this up and let's figure out
a way to get the best fighters in the
world fighting.
But
the UFC to its credit is so the brand
has been marketed so incredibly well in
so incredibly well that the value behind
the UFC brand is so high.
Yeah.
That,
that,
you know,
that's what it is.
A brand behind the UFC is so high that,
that,
that brand is what's on the line if they
finally you see either the best.
Yeah.
And that that's what's on the line.
It's kind of crazy because when we first
started,
when I became a fan,
the one thing that me and my friends sit
around and think that mma needed because
a lot of folks don't know that in 1997
and then may was so underground,
most people had no idea what it is.
And I always said,
you know what?
We need some like crazy billionaires
that happened in be fight fans to just
come along and buy it.
But I never thought that was actually
gonna happen.
And then it would actually be like some
of the nicest fucking guys on the planet
earth,
like Lorenzo in Frankfurt or some of the
nicest fucking human beings you could
ever want to meet that gentleman in
every sense of the word.
They're easy to talk to.
They're friendly,
they're kind,
they're cool motherfuckers.
And they love fights.
They love boxing.
They bet stupid money on boxing.
Like all of the time.
They're big floyd mayweather fans and
they were big ricky Hatton fans and you
know,
they,
they love combat sports.
It's always been a passion for them.
And they,
oh,
they also happen to own 20 casinos.
Yeah,
that helps.
it was like literally like we manifested
them like we created the Joe Rogan.
Thank you Joe Rogan.
I appreciate that buddy.
We needed billionaires to come along and
it's like the,
it's almost like simulation theory,
like you know,
the,
the universe provides you what your
creative imagination is trying to
concoct.
Exactly.
I don't know.
I don't really buy that,
but I do buy that.
We were lucky as fuck to have the
fertittas come along and they spent so
much money to get the UFC to where it is
before they actually started making
money.
That at one point in time they were
thinking about quitting.
They were like 40 something million
dollars in the hole.
That's what people don't know.
People.
People talk about MMA and UFC like it
was a home run.
That was of course,
of course it was going to be big,
right?
It wasn't.
They took and
people that I don't understand who,
who,
who knocked the UFC and and look,
they took the risk and put the money in
when it wasn't a home run,
you know,
when like you said,
they were 40 in the hole and I didn't
super intelligent and they did create a
brand.
They built the brand up and they got it
to where it is and they deserve every
fucking penny.
They knew exactly what.
I think that's,
that's,
that's reality.
You know,
and the sport would not be here where it
is right now if it wasn't for those
guys.
That's just a fact.
If they didn't spend that money and take
that chance,
it's it had to get promoted,
but it's amazing that it did.
You know?
It really is like,
I'm so psyched.
We're going to Chicago this weekend and
I'm going to.
We're going to be fire fights on Fox and
it's great fucking fights.
It's you're going to have rampage versus
glover to sharer.
That's a great fucking fight.
And then pedes versus Serona's happened
for two and Dotson.
Dotson is going to fight for the title.
He's fighting mighty mouse.
That's going to be a sick fight.
That's going to be a fight.
If folks can get past the fact that
these guys weigh 18 pounds,
get past to get past the size.
These 100 and 125 pounds,
they're,
they're the baddest motherfuckers on the
planet earth like pound for pound.
No one moves.
Like these guys.
You want to talk about guys who are
technical,
like mighty mouse is so fucking
technical.
He's so good at mixing up the take downs
with,
with stand up and his.
His timing and his speed and delivery is
sensational and he comes from an
interesting lineage to me because I was
just talking about his trainer Matt Hume
the other day.
There's very few guys that mission
started out,
not just that,
I mean basically every coaching stuff,
but matt hume started out when MMA was.
It was pankration and it was.
I mean,
he was literally in the just post,
post hoists,
gracie wave and add all those guys,
whether it's the lion's den or whether
it's uh,
you know,
the military camp.
All these camps that rose up from those
ranks.
Matt Hume has stayed ahead of the curve
and continue to evolve his teaching and
his game and his fighters to where the
sports at.
Whereas like a lot of guys get stuck.
They get stuck with a certain style.
You know,
there's the hammer house style.
There's fucking lion's den style.
And that style,
as those sport becomes this sort of Rory
Macdonald,
GSP type athletic dominance sport.
The guys who really continued to advance
or rare,
the guys who make it from that early
pioneer age where Matt Hume's fighting,
if you go back and look at Matt,
Matt Hume fought pat melted way before
pat military ever won the UFC title
because no knows where the neat man.
Humans very,
very technical stand up and had good
ground game.
He submitted a Kenny Monday and one of
those submission only matching.
Yeah.
That was something called contenders
I want was like God,
that was.
That was a good contenders or something
with some paper grappling thing.
Frank shamrock submitted data and
understood the heel hook inverted.
He'll hook you up.
Yeah,
that was nasty.
There was a lot of interesting of in Dan
Gable gave commentary on it as well.
I think it was already.
It was already.
It was pretty involved.
I don't remember that.
I remember the matches,
but I don't remember what I was hoping
that that would actually become
something that people could watch
because I think there's something cool
about watching,
like really aggressive submission
grappling.
You know,
if you watch them,
Marcello Garcia,
you watch a jock array or jake shields,
someone who really goes after the finish
and you know,
to see that on television I think would
be really interesting for people,
but,
but that's the part that we have the
most trouble translating May.
That's the part where people start
booing and you know,
and I'm seeing something awesome and
crowd's booing and that's okay.
That doesn't matter.
You can't make everybody happy.
You can see what I'm saying.
But what I'm saying is MMA,
which has a ton of action and some
grappling,
the grapplers part,
we have the people that have at least
attempts to meet with someone that's all
grappling.
That's a hard sell.
They tried to do a real pro wrestling
which Kenny Johnson,
again finishing in that.
The difference I think is in this
submission.
Who watches Abu Dhabi?
I mean guys like us,
but it's not like it's in,
you know,
on Espn.
It's not like it's in the front of
sports illustrated who's the best
strangler on the planet earth.
You know what I mean?
I think that's something that's missing.
I think there's two things that are
missing and I think high level
kickboxing is the other one.
I think like eye level kickboxing,
like k one,
like I know glory.
Just put on a pay per view event.
I think they're going to do something in
America this year and they might throw
in a lot of money.
Yeah,
yeah.
They might be able to pull it off.
I didn't.
I wasn't down with their last thing
because they had like,
I watched it,
I bought the paper you,
but it was four fights in a night.
I was like,
that's crazy.
And they were making the guys fight two
minute rounds for five,
two minute rounds.
I was one out of Japan.
Right?
Was that in Japan?
Because they had a new year's eve show,
I believe it was Japan.
It was.
Yes.
It was because it was in combination
with dreams.
They also,
they did both of them back to back in
the same place and it was incredible.
I mean,
it was a really fucking good fights,
but to see Daniel Gita in the final
round against semi shell just exhausted
having fought three fucking tough fights
and the third fight was against that big
giant dude.
I forget the guy's name,
but he's 300 pounds,
six foot eight.
He's a bad motherfucker and he's he and
you know,
and he beat up on [inaudible].
So it's like these guys are going
through unbelievable punishment before
they ever get to the final fight.
I would way rather see individual
supernatural card.
Yeah.
I don't like tournament's man.
I think it's stupid because I think it's
unfair if one guy wins in a seven
second,
don't take that personally at school to
work on Solo tour tournaments where you
fight multiple times in a night in the
same night.
It just too many variables that are just
who can go through that.
I don't.
I like a tournament format where you
build to one final
contender.
I liked that.
I liked what I liked,
what [inaudible] does.
I like what a dream does,
but what I used to do a couple of the
night opening two in one night.
It's interesting because you want to see
what happens when vandelay meets,
you know rampage and you want to see
what happens when they meet in the
finals,
but variables.
The reality is if you,
if you fight more than one time at
night,
you could be really busted up and maybe
can cuss.
Especially if you're fighting Japan.
Oh my God.
Okay.
That'll stop.
Anything.
They will let you fight.
Even if you're concussed.
If you got concussed in your first fight
and then you go out,
they'll let you go off for the second
flight.
I've,
I've had some people ask me about
recently,
would a mortar thing like glory be
successful?
United States,
I think mmm.
May Have paved the road where people are
used to seeing more Thai and kickboxing
and MMA and appreciating it and we'll
obviously throw the dollars toward a
good Moitai promotion.
I think it can work and I think,
like I said,
the MMA fans that have gotten used to
that kind of striking.
That's what paved the way.
I think a few years ago didn't work.
Yeah,
I think it never did in the United
States.
We never been big on Kik.
Well,
you know what it is as the PKA karate
shit ruined it for everybody because it
was so bad.
It was so.
It was awful.
It was so silly.
I don't watch that.
If you guys listen,
you don't know what we're talking about.
Good.
Don't want to watch it.
Just to see what we're talking about.
They used to have this rule where you
had to throw a certain amount of kicks
in around,
so you had like these sloppy kicks in.
Then you had bad boxing and you had
like.
I mean just.
I'm just going to be honest.
They were inferior athletes.
They just weren't that good and no one
ever looked at the best of the PKA guys
and said,
hey,
that guy could fuck up.
Marvin Hagler.
No one thought they knew that Marvin
Hagler was just going to jump all over
him.
They weren't in the same quality.
I saw some boxers who got into it for
the money and literally went,
went to a different mindset through like
six kicks to get the number they needed
in the round and then they'd box the
rest of the round,
beat the guys at.
It's.
It was a bad style because they didn't
incorporate leg kicks and knees and
elbows and all the things that make
kickboxing and more time more
interesting.
Yeah,
and then once they started doing that
though,
in Japan with k one,
it became some of the most.
It went from being boring as fuck to
some of the most exciting fights in the
history of combat.
Sports were fought in the k one days of
Japan where most people have no idea
they were even going on because in Japan
it was gigantic.
They had Andy Hook and Ernesto hoost and
they put together,
these Japanese are such bad
motherfuckers.
They put together these giant
tournament's featuring the greatest kick
on earth and made them fight each other
on multiple occasions.
One poor tiny Japanese did in there too.
Every now was.
The hilarious part to me is the kind of
freak show matches he used to put
together,
but k one was the shit.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
They was put together.
They would put together some freak shows
while they put together.
Bob Sapp.
Yeah.
Bob Sapp it.
Ernesto hoost is the greatest freak show
match up ever.
I can't believe we lost him.
He wasn't twice,
twice in a row and he had to come back.
He had to come back.
We played that fight and we were like
fucking around doing color commentary on
the show.
We were talking about what an amazing
fight it was like.
Yeah,
he dropped him with a fucking left hook
to the body and hurt him bad.
Like Bob Sapp was hurt bad and Ernesto
was chopping at his legs,
but he was so big and so fucking strong.
That a one.
Anyway,
you know who bob said reminds you of
when it goes down,
ball bowl.
Do you remember the punch out?
Ball ball is.
I like this,
I like that.
And His.
I'll pop out.
The dude looks like ball ball.
Whenever he goes down,
that's fucked up.
You say that because he broke his eye
socket,
remember that fucked his eye up,
and then as I looked weird number ball
ball,
man,
I'm serious.
That happens to do.
They get that eye socket break and then
they develop that one weird because of
that and then they're still fighting.
That's when you know Shit's
real.
When one moves,
the other one didn't know that that's a
problem.
Did Marillo Ninja have brain surgery?
What is the story with that?
I have not heard anything because we
know that you not having brain surgery
and still fight today,
you can have some things done that
actually it's not even like they have to
clean something up like Tiago Alvez
member.
They had an insert like some crazy glue
in his brain and he had a week something
or another.
There was some issue where they did like
a micro surgery and then he was back to
fighting like shortly thereafter,
which is really hard to wrap your head
around that they were inserting glue
into his dome and then they're like,
yeah,
you're good to go get back there and get
fucking shinned in the head again.
Right.
Like we were saying before,
that second generation,
you're starting to go,
so.
And Sony's Danisha Babaloo.
I got my own house.
It's time to pack them my.
And it's hard for us.
Who saw guys like that in warship guys?
Yeah.
La Ballou has one of the scariest old
school valley Tudo knockouts ever.
You remember Brad Kohler,
brand core,
brand Kohler.
Who had one of the best.
We look at Rhino.
Unbelievably muscular,
solid dude.
He had one of the best one punch Kaos
ever and that was an example that we
were talking about before about a
Bressler being able to generate that
same double leg,
take down power into a punch.
And that's what Brad didn't eat.
I forget who the dude was.
It was it both of his arms was bret
cooler?
Yeah,
definitely.
That was
God,
I can't remember his name.
Tall.
Do Tattoos on both arms.
He was really touted as more of a
Jujitsu guy.
Yeah.
He was trying to get ahold of them and
he got.
He got leveled.
Well Bob Lou manhandle,
that dude.
And then he soccer kicked him back in
the soccer kick days and Bob Ballou
soccer kicked him,
like moved his whole body like a foot
when he kicked him,
it was just,
it was one of the most brutal soccer
kick Kaos ever.
And Baba Lou,
that's when he first emerged onto the
scene man.
And he was a dangerous motherfuckers
still is man,
you know,
he's been hit a bunch of times,
has been knocked out bunch of times,
but you know,
anybody could lose if they get caught.
We're spinning back fist like that.
That dude's spun around and blasted him
right behind the jaw.
I mean that,
that was a hot shot.
It was.
And he was still up after that shot.
Took it in Illinois.
Yeah.
You got dropped by the left hook,
but you know he's been in there with so
many guys like thinking about like the
chocolate Dell,
two fights with chuck.
You know those,
those were crazy fight the thing.
The thing is is that the last year has
had have been some brutal ass shot go
gig guard Musashi who was an animal.
The Henderson is one of the most brutal,
you know,
Henry Henderson puts it on you dude.
The guy he is.
That motherfucker has some of the most
violent ground and pound.
It's like he capitalizes on these
openings in ways that a lot of guys
don't like.
It's the suddenness to it.
Like when he starts pounding on you,
you usually don't get up from that.
It's not a lot of guys who are going to
absorb those shots and get up.
He can.
Dan can put some serious fucking
horsepower behind those Naacos.
Man.
I'm,
I was really bummed out when they had to
stop that Jon Jones Henderson fight.
I was really,
really bummed out because,
uh,
I'm so,
especially during that time of his
career when John is like still sort of
learning all the different aspects of
mma.
I mean he's getting better every time
you see him,
but if there's ever an opening for a
veteran,
a real crafty guy like Anderson to
capitalize on a mistake or the open,
open a door by setting some traps and
open the door for him to land a punch.
Dan Henderson knows how to put that
fucking hand on you.
He knows how to do it.
He might not be technical in the sense
of like Cyril,
Dod Bhate who sets things up in that
flow through a wide variety of punches.
It overhand right and good left hook.
But if he hits you,
you're fucks Ville and going out.
And he does it in training a lot too.
It's not like.
So he's developed a way to that works
with his body type,
with his style of fighting and with his
wrestling ability to.
He's developed a way you,
you can't sleep on that.
And I would have thought.
I thought that was a very interesting
first round really to see what kind of,
what,
how the fight shapes up and whether or
not John takes him down.
If John gets on top of him and wears
them out.
Yeah,
that's what I was.
I was wondering like how would this play
out and what do you get clipped coming
in,
you know,
and Dan Henderson clips you,
I don't care who you are,
you've got a really big problem on your
hands and that is a career changer.
It is.
That shit's a career changer.
You know,
like when he blasted out fader,
everybody was like,
Holy Shit.
I said,
I mean,
look,
people have beaten fader and bigfoot
even stopped him in between rounds,
but it was a brutal slow beat down.
Whereas Dan Henderson's was sudden and
violent as fuck.
He ducks under and clips him with an
upper cut under his armpit and just
starches.
I'm just stiffens him up and then boom,
boom.
A couple hammers to the side of the head
and it's over.
I mean,
when,
when Dan gets you hurt,
he fucking jumped on and they're never
the same.
Never says
Dan Henderson fought,
I think it was,
I mean,
Cro cop probably beat the crap out of
annually.
But after,
in my opinion,
after the,
uh,
den Henderson fight,
when he lost his belt and pride,
I was pretty much it.
Vandelay was never that old vander Lee
again.
Ever,
ever.
I think cro cop beat the crew.
Adam Cro,
cro,
cop speed to Kao.
First of all,
when they first fought cro,
cop cro,
cop beat his body up,
but some of the most vicious fucking
left kicks to the body where that
footprint ribs,
this whole ribs were lit up.
But he was so inexperienced that his
timing was a bit off.
He was worried about the takedown and
even instilled some weird law or rule
rather where you can only find in the
ground for like 30 seconds.
Remember those old mixed k ones with
pride.
And the rule was that if no one got
knocked out,
it would be a draw.
So wound up being a draw.
But in the second fight you saw cro cop
where to have quite a few mma fights and
quite a few days in the gym.
Working on a sprawl and his take down
the fence and that was when he was in
his athletic,
at his best.
He was at his best and when he fucking
Shinde him in the head man,
like,
oh Geez.
And you saw it vandelay just go
backwards with his arms up in the air
completely in dreamland.
You're like,
whoa.
I didn't think we'd see vandelay like
this.
When you see enough fights,
especially somebody with a long career
like vandelay or cro cop,
and then you guys can always say one
fight where you kind of go.
That was it,
you know,
and I think was the high point for him.
I think it's Mark Hunt really.
I think Mark Hunt hurt him and he lost
that fight.
We thought he won that fight,
but if anyone that fit,
I thought he wanted to,
but it was a close fight.
Mark Hunt hurt him,
knocked him down.
And Mark,
I think Mark Hunt took some of the wind
out of his sails.
Vandelay always thought of himself as a
striker and that was the first time he
faced a guy who is like ridiculously
pedigreed striker,
k,
one Grand Prix champion and Mark Hunt
when they were standing,
Mark Hunt was putting it on them.
Yeah,
I think vandelay realizing its head like
I'm not even close to the best striker
on earth.
I think that fight shattered his
confidence a little bit without
conferences.
Got like generally can't do any.
Yeah,
because that was the first fight when we
saw him,
like consistently not able to do what he
wanted to do with his stand up and
getting teed off on.
He got tagged a couple of times.
I don't just take down a lot,
which we never saw him before that he
tried to turn it into an mma fight and
we thought from vandelay that he would
welcome a brawl,
but he did not welcome abroad with that
guy.
And I think that was one of those fights
where you know,
you look at like a guy operating like
vander Lee did it.
So many Rpms like hit the folks who've
never seen beverly's fights is his name
is spelled Wanderlei w a n d e r Lei,
and he was like ridiculous to her with
this nickname.
Does it already that nicknamed him that?
I think so,
yeah.
Pretty.
Had a bunch of great nicknames,
but he,
um,
whoever it was,
that nickname that was perfect because
he would fight like a murderer.
He would just come charging at you like
a fucking animal.
He scared the shit out of everybody
being like he was the most aggressive
guy ever in a sport
that's unbelievably aggressive from an
aggressive camp.
Yeah.
Box for that.
And he was like the poster boy for shoot
box.
Yeah,
he was.
When he was in his prime,
he was insane.
Watch if you want to watch him in his
prime watch vandelay Silva versus
Quintin Jackson and pride.
When you see vandelay Silva versus
Quintin in the UFC,
he'd already been flatlined a couple
times.
Cro Cop at Kod,
Dan Henderson and coyote.
Him fighter can only take so many shots
to the head.
There's only so many you have in you and
vandelay eats up a lot of those in
training,
you know,
like vandelay and training is calling
a problem with that.
Sometimes that shoe box mentalities you
use all your juice up training spawn
with guys.
This is the other one.
Trainings are ridiculous.
They had a bet to see who would win a
fight for a pit bull.
Vandelay wanted to buy a pit bull from a
Shogun shogun wanted too much money or
whatever they thought vandelay knocked
him out and took his pit bull.
He knocked his friend for a fucking
puppy.
It like that shoot box man.
And even in,
you know,
to this day Shogun even talks about,
that kind of training that they don't do
that anymore.
That kind of training is bad for the
athletes.
So shogun is not participating in that
kind of training as much.
Anyway.
I think hearkening back to what we're
talking about about it's a sport,
athletes now there's that the
intelligence of we are professional
athletes and I want to have a long
career to make money.
It isn't so much the pride of the
martial artists like it used to be,
which has its ups and downs,
but part of the good side is they're
athletes and they're thinking about
their career and I think about the
longterm of training and rest and that
wasn't always a factor.
Needless to say,
the most important aspect of MMA for
progress is analysis,
analysis,
objectivity and intelligence focus,
dedication,
hard work and techniques.
Having all of those info in place,
you have to be able to analyze what you
need to change,
what you need to adjust and what you
need to put in and what you need to take
out.
That's all technique.
That's being technical,
that's being intelligent and when you
get to a point where you're ultimately
technical,
like a guy like Anderson Silva who's
technique is so evolved and so far
behind or so far ahead of everybody that
he can do.
Nobody shit like standing with his back
up against the cage and go,
come on,
come,
come fight with me.
And Stephan Bonner was so far beyond his
reach with it in terms of technique that
Anderson can get away with that kind of
shit.
You stand right in front of you dodger,
your obvious punches.
There's a president,
there's a point every fighter goes to
where that you don't want to go there.
It's a dark place.
You've got to face sometimes to know
here's the best and here's where I am.
Yeah.
And I'm not there and I'm never going to
be there.
And that's,
that's how it is.
And you see every there,
there are a lot of fighters.
The whole point of fighting any athletic
competitions to go,
how good can I be at this?
How far can I get with everything I get?
There was a point where you go this far.
Yeah,
the Anderson Silva is the best and he's
making me look like an idiot.
It's pretty far below.
That's a hard thing to see
was just really,
you know,
like everyone likes to say you can.
Anything you set your mind to.
Yeah.
Sort of.
Unless John Jones is set in his mind to
doing it too and then doing it alone,
just what you might not be able to do it
because John John's my fuck you up.
You know,
you could say,
well,
you want to be the champion.
You can go and set your mind,
eh,
John John's centers might do it too.
Okay,
and he's.
He's way ahead of you and the physical
curve and that physical curve is so real
and if you don't have the physical gifts
to go along with the dedication and the
athleticism and the training,
most likely you're not going to be
successful anymore.
There's a.
We live in a different era now.
It's not as simple.
It's not as simple as the old days,
but the key to getting anything out of
martial arts is to maximize what you're
personally capable of and maximize your
human potential.
It doesn't mean that everybody who gets
into martial arts has to be a UFC or a
belt or champion.
That's fucking stupid.
Like,
that's crazy.
So to think that,
you know,
it's sad that someone can't make a
career as a UFC fighter.
No.
Most people can't make a career as a UFC
fighter.
Not everyone can be champion.
Maybe you can.
Maybe you can't.
Maybe it's a combination of you need to
be prepared from the right point in your
life,
in the correct way,
and managed in the right forms of
competition so you experienced defeat
and experience all the benefits of
facing adversity or you might not.
You might hurt your back,
you know,
you might.
You live fucking me up and you can't
compete anymore,
but you have to take whatever energy
that allowed you to get very good at
martial arts and use that in some other
way and learn and let you've developed
tools.
You have a whole box full of shit that
you've developed through overcoming
adversity that the average person
doesn't and you can apply that to
anything you want.
Your sporting life.
Yeah,
is six to 10 years if you are real
lucky.
If you aren't sure Josh Barnett,
unless you're in forever,
sorry,
v toward knocks out bisping and he's.
He started out 1997,
1997 and he's still at the top of the
game.
A long prime.
That's 13 years and he's a striker,
which is even crazier.
Christian even make any sense.
I could be that that deep in the game
still keep his chin and still start
people on a regular basis and because
he's had hand problems,
you know,
he's broken his hand like eight blocks.
He's moved to kick and people.
Now he's head kicking people.
I mean,
and with the same kind of speed known as
a punter.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
But the thing that you're like your
athletic prime,
unless you're.
Unless you're a brown hopkins or
something is generally 10 years is a
long time.
How much hgh has he taken?
Let's be honest.
There has to be some hgh,
little testosterone cream.
Not out there.
There's just.
I don't see unless he some genetic freak
specimen,
but it doesn't make any sense anymore.
The fact that you'd be athletically
competitive in his age.
I think the last guy to do it legit was
George Foreman.
I think George Foreman and and not want
to cast aspersions on anybody for taking
performance enhancing supplements,
but we know that they do.
We know that they do.
It's 100 percent that there are certain
athletes,
whether it's in boxing or MMA or in
whatever.
This Lance Armstrong thing,
man drives me fucking crazy.
I say that the real issue with Lance
Armstrong was it,
he's a hypocrite Douche bag and he was a
Douche bag to the people that were
riding with him and he was a Douche bag
to the people that held at
grits about blood doping and everyone
I've spoken to who's dealt with them
terrible human being.
He's a cunt.
So we all say
Lance Armstrong's a con,
but why is he illegit and the other
guys,
are they legit?
Like if you take away his title,
who wins?
That thing is
no winner of the Tour de France.
You know,
they,
they couldn't find anyone.
They couldn't.
What happened was they went down,
they had all dope too.
So they went,
all right,
so there's no winner for these.
17 said for the year and you had to go
all the way back.
10th place to a guy who is this?
A Kalyan dude who had never been accused
or thought of as a doper and never
tested positive 10th place 10th.
You have a legitimate sport man,
and you know it's some doctors say ready
for this.
They say that it's healthy to take epo
and to take blood transfusions and to
take human growth hormone and take
testosterone.
If you're going to do something like the
Tour de France because it's unhealthy,
do it without those things that you're
telling your body to go way beyond its
normal limits.
Way Beyond.
Come on.
You're telling your body to go way
beyond its normal way beyond.
It's boring as fuck.
How about that?
Somebody ride a bike or what?
Riding a bike.
I'm sure it's thrilling.
I'm sure it's great.
Great
to to enforce your willpower and your
determination and the amount of time you
spend on the road.
Just pushing and checking your heart
rate monitor and to know that you're
beating this guy with your discipline,
your hard work and your will to win and
all that good.
However,
nobody wants to watch that shit.
You're riding a fucking bike.
Okay?
You little kid.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Putting breeding.
Nobody's,
nobody's going to watch a sport where
you're,
your bell.
Sounds like this.
Do not have those bells.
They don't have those bells.
She'd have this baseball cards and their
wheels and they should all have those
bells bringing.
You're a little child,
Lance Armstrong,
but it's the old guy on a bike.
What's cheating?
If everybody's doing it,
everybody's doing it was cheating.
It becomes a very real question.
Like they're.
The real issue is at what is allowed.
Can you take vitamins?
Yes,
you can.
Well,
why can you take vitamins?
Why shouldn't you just get everything
you need through your healthy diet?
Because what are you getting out of
those vitamins?
Have you taking more vitamin C than you
could ever get by eating food?
Is there a benefit in that and what
isn't?
Is it show up athletically?
And why should you be able to do that?
I mean,
I'm just using that as an example,
right?
Well,
there was,
uh,
some,
supplement that mark mcgwire they found
in his locker when he was doing,
based on what you guys remember,
that it's interesting,
Diane,
I understand.
And somebody,
an Olympic athlete got banned for life
for that stuff,
but baseball didn't recognize it as a
banned substance.
So he was taking it.
He was saying,
I can totally take it.
They were called pro hormones,
right?
And this was,
there was a bunch of them that
will totally work legit.
One of them was called Mag 10 and they
made this shit illegal.
Do this was fucking steroids.
It was steroids.
I took it,
my nipples hurt.
I got way bigger,
gained like 10 pounds in a no bullshit,
maybe two months,
two months,
10 pounds of muscle.
And it was amazing.
And you got it at GNC.
The only problem was when you got off
that your Dick said cyanotic.
My Dick was like,
dude,
I'm going to take about a month or start
working in a inverted.
So I was like,
I was.
I remember beating off with a half hard
deck.
I'm like,
I have in common like four days and I
still can't get a boner.
My Dick was done for.
Yeah,
it took a while.
Took like it was like at least a couple
of weeks,
like before I felt like normal again
because you were so elevated that your
balls are like,
what are you doing?
I just want you to take and stuff.
I fought a GNC.
GNC used to sell.
They used to sell 'em that date rape
shit.
I'm Ghb.
Yeah.
They used to this stuff that's built by
people overdose on and people throw in
girls drinks and molest them.
Used to be able to buy that at GNC.
GNC has had some legit shit there.
Over the years.
That button,
I never took anything that was as strong
as that mag 10 stuff.
That was.
You had to take a lot of pills to like.
You couldn't be even remotely confused
as to whether or not you're doing
something healthy because you were
taking like 10 of these foul pills a
day.
It was like a lot of pills.
I'm like,
what is the oral toxicity of this stuff?
Like what is it,
what's it doing to my liver?
Who Cares?
Just make you giant.
So they got rid of that.
That became illegal,
which is a,
I think probably a good thing because
anybody like me can just go in and buy
it and like you don't,
you don't know like if you're like an 18
year old guy and you take that stuff.
Like I took it for what it said to take
on the package.
I took it for like six weeks or whatever
it said to take.
But what if you're an idiot?
What if you take it every day for a year
and then all of a sudden you're,
you have like cancer,
like your body shuts down.
Like you're,
you know,
you have like liver issues or you might
get asked to get a transplant.
One of prescription medication is that a
doctor tells you how often to take it
and he can only take it for a certain
amount of time.
It's the whole point.
You shouldn't be able to just buy
something in Gnc that can jack,
you know it.
It shouldn't be possible.
Should be like buying calcium.
Well,
you take it,
what happens if you take too much?
You know,
like who cares?
Just be fine,
but if you take like some of those like
mag 10 type things,
like you could shut your whole endocrine
system.
Done.
Yeah.
You're whole.
You're fucking pituitary glands.
Like what are you doing asshole?
Like your body doesn't know what to do
without your gonads shrink.
Like I know a dude who is maybe in his
thirties and he cannot have a child.
He's trying to have a child with his
girlfriend and his wife now.
They can't.
They can't have a child.
And so they went to the doctor and the
doctor said,
did you have a sperm count of a 70 year
old man?
You just,
you broke your Dick,
you broke it.
It's all broken now because he was a
bodybuilder when he was young.
Apparently it was gigantic at one point.
That candle that Burns twice as bright
burns half as long.
That's it,
dude.
No candle.
If you make yourself do something
extraordinary,
it makes your body go beyond its limits
for too long.
It comes back way lower than it.
Then it went in.
That's why it's fast in the natural.
It's the way it goes,
man.
See Bodybuilding change from like the
uh,
what is his name?
Reeves Day was that guy's name George
[inaudible] or Steve Back in the day.
Yeah.
I mean they were like,
you know,
they were built like,
um,
like when you have a comic books,
so they went like,
it would be able to like,
you know,
Charles Atlas?
Yeah.
They were like solid,
you know,
powerful looking men.
But they weren't like these weird skin
tight vascular freak alien looking dudes
that you see today where they,
there's a picture of this guy flexing
his ass and his ass looks like.
It's like,
it looks like ropes.
It looks like someone's taken some giant
like shipyard rope and made an ass out
of it.
Like it's all coordinated and if the guy
has no body fat on,
like it can't be healthy there,
but I probably can't even walk up a
flight of stairs.
He was ready to die.
I don't,
I don't get about bodybuilding
seriously.
I don't.
Why?
The mentality of bodybuilding kind of is
when is it okay,
I'm good now because it's like finding
is my.
If I train hard enough to beat this guy
and if I did that,
I train hard enough.
Right?
If it's my ass doesn't look enough like
a rope or whatever,
like when there's no clinical and the
bargain.
Just do a drop.
Yeah.
Your bar barking.
Just go up and up and up.
I don't get that.
Well,
you go back and look at all arnold who
was a fucking petri dish of chemicals,
like self admitted that he took steroids
and you look at it when you see him but
was nowhere near big enough to compete
today.
Dorian Yates,
guys,
all those guys.
Just unbelievably big.
There's,
there's guys today that they don't even
look real.
They don't look real.
So you look at our old,
like back in the day when he was.
He was more like a Greek God.
Yeah.
It was way lean but still filled with
roids.
Yup.
It's like the changing of the
perspective of like what we think of is
a big muscular man.
Like now it's like cartoonish.
Unachievable Shit,
it's like you saw like Franco Columbo,
that's a perfect example.
Like that is reachable I think without
steroids.
I think with great genetics or Frank
Zane even better example.
Yeah.
Frank Zane was.
He looked like a lean,
athletic,
muscular,
well proportioned guy.
He looked achievable.
He had a normal size neck.
He had a normal sized set of shoulders.
It was achievable.
Whereas a guy like Dorian Yates looked
like it was going to expose us.
Look like the hulk,
dude.
I just explode onstage.
Flex sport freaks me out of all the
crazy shit.
I have seen an MMA combat sports.
I can't watch powerlifting.
Oh,
because I just wait for that moment.
Which does happen sometimes when the
need just explodes.
A hand grenade,
man,
when these guys are power cleaning,
just ungodly weight and your back just
goes.
It just turns to powder like you're done
and posted.
This goes bad.
It goes so bad.
I cannot watch it.
It's horrible to watch any,
any.
If you.
Especially if you're on espn two in the
morning when the top of their head,
the fucking cliff and it lands in their
head.
Here's a whole bad hosted,
a threat on the underground about
rolfing.
Look,
if anybody had back issues.
I was saying I'm having some success
with this.
She's tried out and someone posted an
animated Gif of this kid,
really skinny kid and he gets into a
Smith machine,
has got all this weight on and he curls
it back to release it and then drops
straight down on his neck is like knee,
knee is touching face and the bars on
top of his neck.
I don't even know if he lived.
It's horrific to watch,
but these motherfuckers,
they post that in these threads and they
don't even let you know if they're going
to post something like that.
So you like scroll down and then you're
like,
why the changes you dead?
Kind of like this video.
Well this is the video.
The Bulgarian guy who was a politician,
someone tried to assassinate him.
Check this out.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Jammed.
He stepped up,
put the gun to his face.
Wow.
That guy.
Dude,
that guy had some crazy eyes,
man.
Look at this guy's eyes
right here.
Tried to reload it and it's tried to
unjam it didn't work.
Then they played.
Let's beat the guy up for an hour.
No Man.
It looked out calm.
The Guy Swat away the gun.
Oh,
they beat him up for an hour.
They're just.
All these old men are just like fucking
beating the fuck out of it.
What are they saying?
I wish I knew what they were saying.
I think the translation is kick him.
Kick him out,
kick him.
Love Bulgaria.
Also,
I want to move and I think this is a
peace conference.
They had that in America.
Kick his ass.
See,
I would not be able to stop myself from
breaking his arms.
I got to dude's arm back there and he
just tried to assassinate someone.
I'm going to break into this fucker.
He cannot show that I'm snapping your
shoulder.
Pulling his pants down.
Then they're going to shove something
up.
Is that I would shoot him in the ass
hole right in the asshole.
Take his gun where they've given him a
Wedgie.
I would take his gun and shoot him in
the asshole on TV.
I'm like,
we're all cool with this,
right?
I'm just gonna.
Shoot him in his ass hole right up
through the asshole.
How many people have died that way?
Probably a lot.
Like how many guys?
What's your definition of?
A lot more than a million in the time
that we've had guns that millions of
lives.
Millions of lives.
More than 100.
That's crazy.
That dude attacked them,
attacked him.
He didn't just stand there,
but he went with the push.
Would have been great if he killed them.
How about if the old dude head kicks
from right here?
That is the old dude touches the gun
with his left and then fucking Liotta
Machida's and with the right high cap.
Some great security by the way,
and whatever cost you that as you walk
up to a guy giving a speech and put a
gun to his outstanding secret service or
the PPK.
A little tiny ass gun.
Yeah,
that was a.
that's a little fucking banana republic
right there.
That is hilarious.
The guy shot him.
He would be king the king and they give
him the throne.
Made it a molten swords,
like just like game of thrones,
game of thrones reference,
because you haven't given anybody.
Never do watch TV.
I'm on TV every week.
I never watched TV.
You don't watch anything but you're on
TV.
You don't watch like history channel,
swamp people.
You never seen swamp people.
Dude,
I just don't watch a lot of TV.
I,
I'm fascinated by a reality shows where
people live and somewhere fucked up.
Like I'm fascinated by people that have
to do with nature all the time.
The problem is my wife said reality TV
producer,
so I just hear the backstory of all the
bullshit.
It's not true,
you know,
but they really are killing those
alligators on swamp people.
You can't get around that.
Can I get around and I don't like
alligators.
I've never liked alligators.
Likes an alligator man.
You know?
I think that people are fascinated by
all these animals,
but I would just rather have them all
dead broke.
Extinction is asthma.
They make good bags and Shit,
you know?
But cons,
they're conti.
Old dinosaurs.
Everywhere we'd be fucked.
This is my thought about dinosaurs.
Okay.
If we had dinosaurs roaming the streets,
we'd be,
fuck,
we don't want dinosaurs.
It's cool that we know what these two
look like,
but we don't want to back.
Alligators are fucking dinosaurs.
They eat people.
There was a guy who was running.
It was a great story.
Actually.
It guy was running from the cops two
years ago.
He is in a high speed.
Chase,
pulls the car over to the side road,
jumps off because his water like at a
bridge and jumps off in the water,
lands right next to an alligator.
Alligator eats some right in front of
the cop.
Instantly the guy lands in the water
shocks.
Alligator.
Alligator grabs them,
drags them under gator roll of death,
and that's for the cops.
It's like a goddamn clinics would movie.
So in that sense I liked the Indiana
Jones Temple of doom action.
In that sense.
It's cool to have.
It would be cool to have a moat if you
had a big giant house and emote filled
with her,
but you'd want crocodiles,
but then you can't trust those moment.
They'll come out and Jack you.
Dude,
you got to provide them every now and
then on the back yard and they'll eat a
dog or something called the swamp and
like drag a little kid drowned them.
Oh yeah.
Well I lived in Florida and I didn't see
it,
but I was there when a lady got her a
dog.
Eaton snapped it right off the leash.
She had a poodle,
poodle one to the water to get some,
you know,
get a little drink in the fucking
alligators was like,
bitch,
what they do
man.
I just took him right into the water
then.
Nope.
I didn't hear of a person dying,
but that's just because they didn't fuck
up.
I mean if you fuck up and out,
it's not like an alligator like doesn't
want to eat.
You think people are kind of Nice to me.
You know,
it's like your,
your reality is they don't understand
that at all.
They'll eat anything that stands still.
There is a,
there's A.
I was down in Louisiana and I went to a
gator farm and they said there's a,
they call a one foot rule.
An alligator eat anything a foot bigger
than it is.
If you're bigger than that,
it can't swallow you so it doesn't
really attack you,
but if you're five foot and you're six
foot,
it will eat you,
which is just crazy to think about
because I saw a lot of five foot
alligators.
I saw a lot of them
even creepier than an alligator's.
The Komodo Dragon.
No,
I remember it was.
It was bite the super toxic,
but you remember what the fuck is her
name from
the.
Oh,
Sharon stone.
Shit.
Yeah.
Basic instinct.
Share House by a Komodo dragons.
Dumb ass
went into a Komodo dragon cage barefoot
with socks on and they saw the white
sock and they thought it was a rabbit
because they feed them rabbits,
so he jumped on his foot.
Clamped down is a fucking real live
dinosaur.
It's 20 feet long.
Okay.
These are the biggest lizards on the
planet earth and by the way,
it's got botulism and its saliva.
Yeah.
Scott,
unbelievably toxic saliva,
so much so that they kill animals by
biting them and then following it.
They wait around until they die.
It's horrible to watch
water buffalo video where they do that,
this,
this Komodo dragon sneaks up on his
water buffalo and just gets it on the
leg just a little.
And the water buffalo gets away a little
bit and then you see him like,
Oh shit.
And they see in trying to get away a
little more and it's like,
oh shit.
And then later on they edit the video
and the Komodo dragon just eating its
guts,
just pulling chunks of meat off of its
carcass and like,
you know,
as a,
as an athlete,
I don't need that.
It was a guy who trains in,
let's say percentage wise,
myself and Joe Rogan
can beat up 99 percent of people walking
around on the street.
Anybody smaller than me,
but he doesn't know how to fight exactly
like you will fuck them up.
Right?
So if you're not paying attention
exactly now and you don't have the
letter,
we're screwed.
And you have a cold,
crude Komodo Dragon.
Yeah,
we fucked,
fucked you fucked.
And you're so screwed.
A shark.
That friend of mine was surfing a
deadline to meet you,
so a 14 foot tiger shark and he goes,
it went underneath my board and he's a
good fighter man,
and he goes,
I was like,
I'm screwed at that thing.
Just turns to me.
He goes,
ah,
yeah,
I think I'll eat him that I'm screwed.
Just let me try it.
That's part of the natural kingdom.
Human beings are not designed to take on
very many animals,
especially.
We're getting our ass man.
You can't even.
Oh Shit.
It might be able to fight off a mountain
lion if you kick him in the Dick or
something crazy,
you know,
you might be able to just piss him off.
You might be able to arm drag him gifts
with your back to Leo.
Can you choke a line for real?
I don't know,
but I mean if you scrap one of them
enough where
he thinks it might be an issue,
he might run away,
but sharks aren't gonna run away to
each you a lot of tigers,
not gonna run away.
No one's going to eat you.
Tigers are 1 million and oh,
against people.
No one's ever undefeated in a fair fight
and not natural geographic video with
the guys on a,
on a on an elephant and you don't see
anything.
You're looking at all this grass and
they're looking for a tiger.
They killed some people,
whatever,
and you don't see anything and that
thing leaped and I've been on the back
of an elephant before in India.
You're high.
It doesn't occur to you to someone could
jump up there and get you slashes that
dude's arm severely.
He got fucked up.
You got fucked up,
but he stayed on the line like a
gangster or stayed on the elephant or
gangster.
Well,
that dude.
Yeah,
yeah.
Pull that video up because it's a tiger
leaps onto India.
It's in India.
We'll see what happens.
That video.
We'll watch the video that's not
national geographic's on top of that
shit.
I don't give a fuck.
Pull it up.
Whatever it is.
Want to see it right now.
Let's find out.
Yeah.
Youtube has been yanking out.
You know,
it's Hilarious,
but youtube,
youtube will take our videos down
because we just started uploading them
to youtube.
If we use videos that are from youtube,
so that's like youtube a little,
I'm a little confused.
The snake eating its own tail for a
copyright issue.
If you use a video that you got from
Youtube and then you upload that to
Youtube,
youtube is like you are infringing on
someone's copyright and you're like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
That's your.
That's your shit.
I got it from your site.
Like what?
What is happening here?
Or are you kind of the snitch or is
letting them know that there's
copyrighted material now?
I don't think so.
I don't think that's what the issue is.
That's weird because otherwise they
would know that it's there from them
because they're some sort of thought.
The way they get it from you is like
they,
they like send out this Bot or you know,
have some program rather than analyzes
all the youtube videos and finds out
whether other's music.
And I'm finding and when it is just you,
this is copy written stuff,
you can't,
we're not going to get sued because we
let you upload that Shit.
So you figured once they have something
that's on youtube and they keep it on
youtube,
well that's,
you know,
they've already got that.
That's,
that's on their site.
So if you show it on their site as well,
it shouldn't be an issue at all.
But apparently it is.
That's crazy.
It was crazy because that one song that
we played didn't get taken down the
Michael Jackson one.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
The a member of the two guys dancing in
the street,
a Mick Jagger that didn't get taken down
that David Bowie,
Mucinex,
what got us.
God is but not because of the music,
because I guess family guy had that in
an episode,
that video in the episode so that it got
taken down for family guy.
Are you kidding me?
They must have bought the rights to that
video if you haven't seen that.
It is.
I forgot how gay is the gas jagger ever.
And,
and,
and fucking David Bowie got there was,
it was so bad.
It was unbelievable.
But I couldn't believe that anybody
would think that that would be like,
oh,
here's the tiger.
Okay,
well there to look at fucking thing
running
unopposed,
lying up to this whole jacked.
His arm was injured covertly.
Oh Dude.
A bit.
His fingers off man.
You see that shit man.
It's like missing a shot.
We don't see anything.
There's some shot coming up with a list
where you don't see.
Look at.
You're looking at all this grass.
There's nothing there and then it just
comes out and it's like you'd done that
thing bit off.
Half of that dude's hand.
Imagine that thing coming at you when
you're not on an elephant,
you just screwed.
Kiss your ass goodbye.
It's amazing that it gave up bit off
half of his hand and then gave up.
It doesn't like curry.
I'm looking at this.
Oh,
you suddenly look at this show.
Just bites off.
Fucking fingers.
Son could've just as easily done that to
his head.
Oh yeah.
I mean there are such frightening
animals,
man,
and the amount of people in India that's
been killed by them.
It's.
I was in India during a fight quest and
they were near this river and are
wanting this stream thing and the guy
turns around and goes,
oh,
I would stay away from scheme,
mini cobras,
cobras,
and I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to be over here.
Like cobras.
Like,
oh,
there's a mouse in my basement.
I know there's a rat in my basement.
It's like,
Oh,
there's a cobra.
My basement.
How many people die?
Cobras are fricken lot because they were
like,
I always knew the street when they went.
Oh,
many cord was there yesterday and I was
like,
ma'am,
oh,
out out dude.
The cinder bands is an area in India
where 300,000
people over the last 200 years have been
killed by tigers.
They started keeping track when I
started realizing their deliciousness,
300,000
people over 200 years.
That just makes my head hurt.
Man.
That really makes my head hurt.
Like,
what are you guys doing that as a
population of a medium sized city?
Yeah.
That's a lot of people to give up to
animals.
Like Long Beach has like 500,000
people.
But meanwhile they're like still like
try to like keep those things alive,
you know,
they,
they work on conservation and they do
man,
they do,
they,
they have like a census team for tigers
and these guys have to go with these
special helmets on with masks on the
back of them because it tigers don't
like to sneak up on you or they liked to
sneak up on you rather.
So they put a mask on the back of their
head.
These poor folks are wandering around
all brass job ever.
Think about that tiger in the tall
grass.
How it ran.
It was running through the tall grass
and we couldn't see it from above and
no,
if you're on the ground and the grass is
higher than your head and you're there
with two other dudes who have rifles.
Have you heard anything buddy?
What is that noise?
I hit a bunch up and that is the last
thing he like.
Oh no,
it's a giant orange and white monster.
Fly done.
And I'm going to try to like shoot it
with a little rifle.
Get off a shot before it malls,
me and my friend.
And what would you do if it just dove on
your right in front of a.
You will be so freaked out which even be
able to operate that bolt.
Would you even be able to pull that
trigger?
Your ass will be gone,
Bro.
I've been like if I'm walking with Joe
Rogan and I get bitten by a ton.
Tiger leaps out of the tall grass.
Joe Rogan's out.
He's doing mental math going spot and
take him four minutes to eat.
Jimmy.
Yeah,
I'm saying four minutes maybe and I
don't want them to be the muscle.
Walk away.
How far away can I walk in?
Four minutes is what your head is
saying.
You don't want to insult as intelligence
either though.
You don't have to tell you to go pitch.
You don't think I know you're running.
Maybe he'll respect you more if it just
actually try to save yourself and just
actually run.
Would you actually whistle
just going back a fucker.
Just going to back up.
You do the Diaz.
I don't know if that.
I wonder if bear spray would work on a
tiger like bear mace,
that fucking hot pepper spray.
I think we just piss him the fuck off.
That's the last thing you want.
He starts eating you Dick First.
Let's say outrun your friends.
Only method of getting out of a
tigertext outrun your friend.
Whoever you're with,
a tiger kills you.
They'll just kill you.
There's a lot of animals that would just
fuck you up.
Like if you get attacked by chimps,
they're going sauces.
Yeah,
they're gonna.
They're not.
They might not have kill you.
You might die,
but they're just going to torture you
and rip you apart.
A chimpanzee is seven times stronger
than a.
give me seven times stronger.
I did a thing with the chimp once and it
was a baby and it was really weird.
It was only like two years old,
but it was like on my back and shit and
he was hitting me.
It was for news radio.
I don't even think we wound up using it,
but the chip I swatted me on the bag of
leaves a little baby and I was feeling
so sing and then I was like,
man,
I'm so soft.
I'm so mushy.
Like in comparison to him,
like he was sinewy like they're made out
of a different thing and he was still a
little sweetie,
you know,
he's like a little.
He would hug him and stuff and he was.
He was a baby basically,
but he was already getting ridiculously
strong.
I used to do a show called American
Ninja Warrior,
which is that that thing he's been on g
four thing where it's like the hardcore
competition and one thing we always
said,
me and Nicole is going to man.
I's more like God,
I'd love to see a chimp go through.
This would almost be insulting.
Just watching chimpanzees will fly
through this.
All these humans are fallen and can't do
it.
And like,
well they did that maybe minutes.
Did you ever see that thing?
They did.
They did a show like it was like man
versus nature where they did like a dude
with sprint next to a Giraffe,
a giraffe with sprint,
but they did a empathetic.
Yeah.
Compared to the chimp and a navy seal.
And I think,
I think that dude,
I don't know who fucking one.
I think the chimp might've got bored
somewhere along the way and not figuring
out what the fuck.
Like I feel like the chimp one but I'm
not sure.
I just feel like if they knew what you
were trying to do,
like get,
you know,
they know.
Are you serious like you are you really
trying to go as hard as you thought we
were playing?
Man,
I totally understand.
It's hard to motivate to do certain
shit.
Yeah.
Like why would he go like to go as hard
as he can for survival sake.
Like why would he do that when you're
essentially doing that,
if you like on your mom did set go,
you're going with every fiber of your
being and this champ is just kinda like
lazy swinging on whenever he wants to
do.
Does he understand competition now?
All those kinds of survival,
it led to people going for it's food.
Yeah.
Knows.
Outrun that thing.
Yeah.
He might know that asked to get there
faster than you to get a cookie or some
shit.
Yeah,
because otherwise you're not going to
really see what he could do and he would
get off the fucking ladder and beat your
ass here to compare to the animal
kingdom.
We are physically pathetic.
Yeah.
You're lucky that chimp doesn't want to
really talk shit.
He'll like,
why are we swinging?
I'll just come over there and bite your
fingers off.
Dude.
That was one good thing about that.
The most recent a planet of the apes as
if they were kind of realistic about
chimp behavior and the Cim holds up
dudes down and bites his finger off.
Yeah.
That's what they do.
That's kind of their thing.
That's the real move.
Screw that man.
The fucking creepy ass fighting.
Pull your dick off.
Pull your feet off.
Pull your nose off.
Didn't even try to kill you.
At least a tiger just kills you.
Straight over you.
Yeah.
Okay,
so you go to some use chimp would
probably eat you.
They're hungry,
right?
Chimpanzee.
They're not meaning or something like.
Oh yeah,
they eat monkeys.
A chimp.
What size?
Chimp would eat a monkey.
He never seen that.
I've never seen.
I've never seen this.
You've gotta see this pull up.
I've been on orangutans.
Orangutans,
chimpanzees.
Hold this up.
Oh yeah.
I don't think orangutans,
chimps,
chimps.
So one of their favorite dishes is
monkey eat him alive,
man.
That's what's fucked up.
They don't even kill them.
They tried to get them like hip first.
They grabbed him by the.
They tried to get me.
They tried to give me those gross stuff
on [inaudible],
which I didn't mind doing.
I'll eat crow stuff.
Doesn't matter what kind of shit they
tried to do it.
And the Philippines and legs.
Fear Faculty,
Filipino friends bring it right.
And then so,
but one thing they want to be,
he was in Korea that had to be live
octopus.
The octopus is like fighting and trying
to get out of your mouth and that's just
cruel.
Like I don't mind.
I love octopus,
but I'm not gonna eat something that's
physically fighting me and striving to
stay alive and shit.
I always love octopus Sushi until I
found out that most of it's cooked.
Yeah,
mostly just kidding.
I didn't know that.
I thought they would tell you if it's
Sushi.
They would tell you if it's cooked,
you know,
I'm not supposed to go.
Thank you.
My friend was Greek and they cook.
The octopus and grilled octopus are
smart as fuck.
A lot of people get kind of bummed out
of people kill an octopus because
octopus have like a really high level of
intelligence.
It makes them delicious and that.
Yeah,
whatever it is makes it does just maybe
it's all that intelligence you have.
What?
Maybe it'd be smart if they had bums.
Okay,
so this is these chimps setup this cds
or like infrared,
see what's going on.
It's like if they back it up,
they.
They chased these chimps down.
Are these chimps?
Chase these monkeys down and cut them
off at the pass and then
watch.
They're all screaming while they have
this and watch how they eat it.
Man,
they eat this little monkey a lot.
They got a hold of them and they just
start pulling it apart.
These dudes are running to try to film
this because it's like the first time
that anybody had ever observed this back
before they observed this.
They thought that chimps were just
eating berries.
They never knew that they the the
monkeys.
Do you see it?
That part where it tears them apart.
It didn't show.
It.
Didn't show them.
That one does a censored one.
There's the same video.
There's the full version of fried
chicken.
He's grabbing it in the monkeys,
like going like this shit and he's
literally eating him hip first sucks.
They're mean,
they're mean little motherfuckers and
they'll kick your ass or they're closely
related to us.
Yeah,
that explains a lot.
I wonder if during like the Roman days
they ever had human versus chimp fights.
I,
I do have a history degree.
I remember reading it as soon as the
rest of the lines a lot and they would
put humans versus various,
you know,
fought against lines or whatever.
What would they let them use a from
things that I've seen,
man,
it would have like a like pike type
weapons,
like spirit type stuff.
Yeah.
What was fucking fucked up where people.
The ones that actually made the Asian
line,
the north,
there was a European lion at one point
and it's extinct now.
They made an advantage.
They took so many of them and use them
for various purposes that they're,
they're extinct.
They.
There was a European line and South
Europe and now it's gone.
This is the full version where you're
going to see the chimp tear it apart.
Then they start screaming and yelling
and making noises and all the other ones
they,
they run in and watch,
watch other pulling this fucking.
They're just ripping this thing apart.
This is a different video because this
one is on the ground.
The most disturbing one was the,
the uh,
yeah.
Looking at me eating the fucking monkey.
The most disturbing one was there was a
video of the monkey in the tree and the
chimp has the monkey up in the tree and
he's tearing apart while he's up there.
And it's like
the monkeys phase going,
fuck,
there's so much
close to people,
you know,
a little monkey faces.
Like,
you really feel bad for him.
You really feel bad when it's good.
It's limbs ripped off and they're
getting eaten by another thing that has
sort of a people face,
you know,
it's like,
Whoa,
this is the closest animal to us
people.
People I think have a very kind of
Disney view of nature in many ways.
And it doesn't work that way.
Man is vicious.
Human beings are vicious to.
But yeah,
I've been talking about that in my act
recently about,
because someone got mad at me for a
jacket with me,
but I had a fake fur jacket and some
woman actually said that,
um,
I,
I don't like what you're tracking
represents.
And almost like fake for.
She goes,
well,
I don't,
I don't like what it represents.
And I was like,
what?
Killing fake animals.
I was like,
I started talking about this on stage
because it really is true.
It's this weird,
crazy.
Like this is not a real cookie.
Like this is not a real animal.
But the,
the idea is that you shouldn't for well
do you know what happens to animals if
you don't kill them?
If the human doesn't turn them into for
they get eaten by wolves,
they get eaten alive by wool,
they get ripped apart.
Guts first,
they chew them apart and then they eat
them and they eat their feet and they
eat their head and then they ship them
out in a big,
not afer and hair,
teeth and shit.
And that's what happens to you if you
don't get turned into a jacket,
like our idea that these,
these beautiful within creatures are
then taken and turned into terrible
things that people wear.
And it's a god he representation of our
cruelty.
Okay.
You'd rather get eaten by a wolf.
Well,
the fee,
there's a great,
there's a great book called the
Omnivore's dilemma and it's about this
guy tries to.
It's about food and where food comes
from and he goes hunting and he kills a
pig and eats it.
And he goes,
he goes,
I felt bad.
And then I realized because he wasn't a
hunter guy like,
and I kinda grew up my family hunts and
stuff,
and uh,
he goes the death that,
that pig died instantly,
which is a way better death than it's
ever going to get in a wild river by
some animal.
Either it gets old and get some diseases
and rots from the inside break.
So terribly pleasant.
Death.
Well,
by the way,
it gets eaten by pigs.
Yeah.
How about that?
You're fucking pigs are hungry and a pig
dies until just cannibalize the fuck out
of you.
So cruel world to take real world.
Many times people falling into pig pens
and been eaten by pigs.
Yeah.
They found a farmer recently.
They don't know if he had a heart attack
or what happened,
but they were looking for him.
They found his fucking clothes in the
pig pen ripped apart and covered in
blood.
Yeah,
that's a pig.
Pigs can go fuck themselves.
Yes.
Oh my God.
That's one of the greatest.
You know,
that guy breaks up with his top crazy
glasses shit.
Hence the 10 greedy,
like a pig is awesome.
He treated his English tea.
Yeah.
That was a great fucking movie about
English gangsters and fighting and pigs
and such a romantic thing.
It's kind of a funny thing.
We met Jason Statham.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Is it a lot of fights?
He was an affliction when I did the
affliction.
Fights.
Yeah.
He loves fights.
He's one of those deals.
Very,
very nice guy.
He's one of those digital places.
Same Cat in every fucking move over and
over.
I'm brought in to kick ass
parker movie.
That looks like every other movie he
does.
Some actors,
man who just find that niche and go,
all right.
I'm always going to be that guy.
I was going to play that guy forever.
Many years.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
Diversifying.
I'm just.
This is my niche.
I'm going to run with it.
Yeah.
Eddie Bravo was going.
You know what's important about him
though?
He's a action hero.
He's a sex symbol and he's bald.
He goes,
we need more of that shit to to.
It was really funny.
It's true.
He's like the first guy with like a
receding hairline in years to pull that
shit off.
I wonder how he was like,
how did he do it?
But other guys couldn't do it.
You know,
like burt reynolds couldn't do it.
Like why didn't burt reynolds realize
that he
couldn't do.
I've been here for years.
I don't like my hair.
I just don't like my hair.
It has nothing to do with any.
Like I have curly hair,
so I don't like it.
The Godfather.
Now when you have something,
that's what I looked like.
Cubes Bright.
Absolutely.
An extrovert on this.
What would you have?
Curly hair.
How's it affect the pubes are the extra
curly so they,
you know,
because your pubes are almost always
curly anyway.
If you have straight hair.
Like my hair is pretty straight,
but my no significant differently.
No,
no significant difference.
Those are going to be different.
Black people got a weird with the pubes
it's like,
wow,
that's craziness.
She django.
Yes.
Jen.
Jamie Foxx is junk.
Exposed to the world is about to get his
nuts off of them.
Yeah.
They grabbed them and they remember
that.
It's not think those are real or were
those like 10 people asked me that it
was ruined my walking out of the movie
and I'm like,
probably.
Unless you had some particular
objection.
Oh yeah.
Every dude was holding his nuts in the
theater by the way.
Very realistic.
That's what they used to do to people.
They did it and it sucks.
That's really fucked up when you really
think that.
That was a couple of hundred years ago.
Yeah.
Really ridiculous.
It's like really not even.
Not even 200 years ago.
What the fuck man?
Like what a,
what a wacky fucking species human
beings are.
I have.
My grandfather was really,
really old when he married my
grandmother,
he was like 50 50 in his mid fifties and
she was 17 when I got married.
My Dad's Dad,
so my dad's dad was born in 18,
81.
His parents could have owned slaves.
That's my great grandfather.
Now.
It's weird because there's this big age
gap in my family,
but yeah,
my great grandfather could have been.
I moved.
Were they from American tucking back
then in the hills of Kentucky for lead
forever.
One was poor as shit,
so maybe they had slave.
It must've been my family for my band
was sharecropping,
uh,
not,
not the plantation on an family.
My family.
Now Kentucky is a strange place,
man.
You telling me so strange that the,
they call the Cincinnati airport,
but it's in Kentucky.
Yeah.
They don't want to call it the Kentucky
Airport because Kentucky's got such a
low,
a pink people have such a low opinion of
Kentucky that they call the airport,
the Cincinnati area.
My Dad's from there,
so I can say it,
but it's in Kentucky that it's like you
land in Kentucky and they call the
Cincinnati airport and then you have to
drive to Cincinnati and like,
why are you pretending that shit is
going down in Cincinnati?
Like you have a border and this is your
border,
but I guess the land was cheaper to put
a fucking airport and conducted must've
men.
And then they just said,
let's just call the Cincinnati airport.
Fuck it.
That's ridiculous.
Well,
it's because there's a massive
insecurity with that state that state
has always thought of Banjos and you
know,
you see the same movie,
lawless with the moonshiners.
You just Shai Lebouf in.
They're no good.
That's my family.
It's about moonshiners.
Your family was like bone loop,
big time moonshiners and like,
you know,
and well my dad always told me this is
really true and I've carried this with
me a long time.
He goes,
uh,
people ideal as country life.
It's violent as shit.
It was really violent back there.
It was.
People had a problem.
You killed the other guy who buried him
in the woods and I was at.
That happened all the time.
It doesn't happen all the time is people
thinking he knows,
you know,
this ideal at country staff.
He goes and the people had a problem,
you know,
one guy disappeared and that was the way
it went.
The beef that go back 50 years and
stuff.
That's,
that's where my dad's from.
Jeff's winter's bone.
I have not heard it was good though.
Is that chick from the crying game or
the hunger games rather than game
criteria is one of the guy has a dick
girl?
Yes.
It's a really fucking creepy movie about
the south,
about a guy who turns up missing and
then the police are looking for them and
they don't want to give away any.
But it was really fucking good movie
about that.
About how,
you know,
this is our idealized view of Oh,
just good old country folks are a lot of
people smoking meth and there's a lot of
people that disappear and I'm not going
to find them either by the way.
No fucking crocodiles out there.
And there's,
I mean,
how many in the everglades to find a
body in the everglades if you have
terrible,
terrible luck.
Some alligator hunters would come by
your floating corpse.
Yeah.
And then they'll,
they'll call the cops,
but most likely they're going to eat
that thing.
Done.
The stories I saw in that movie,
I was like,
my dad told me the exact same stories,
man.
His cousins and shit.
Really?
Yeah.
That's fine.
Isn't it amazing to the dol?
That shit came about back when alcohol
was illegal.
That's where all.
That's where everything came from.
Yeah.
All that organized crime Al Capone Type
Shit,
you know,
that was the birth of the criminal
empire in this country is the fact that
they were suppressing people and keeping
them from having booze.
Yeah.
When,
when,
when?
It's true,
when society and laws don't match,
when something socially acceptable,
it's not legally acceptable.
There's a problem.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
you know it whenever you have that
disparity.
Yeah.
When socially it's not a big deal and
legally it's a big problem.
That's a problem.
Yeah.
It's unavoidable.
People are just like,
fuck,
you know,
marriage is illegal in California.
Nobody buddy in California really cares.
It's not like the laws lag behind what
people really find socially acceptable.
That's always gonna happen.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
isn't it?
And you know,
when it comes back to mma,
the fact that it's still illegal in New
York City,
disgusting in New York state drives me
fucking crazy and that it all comes from
a corrupt union,
that it comes from the culinary union
trying to strong arm station casinos and
to go in union.
It's,
it's crazy ridiculous.
And people drive to Jersey and watch
shows.
It's crazy.
It's crazy that it's illegal.
You're not anything.
You're losing a fuck load of revenue for
the city to millions and millions and
millions of dollars.
They could mean qmap if they have like
an Alistair overeem versus Cain
Velasquez,
heavyweight title fight in Madison
Square Garden be awesome.
Holy fucking shit.
Holy Shit.
But they can have kickboxing.
So glory could put on a big event,
a big kickboxing event at Madison Square
Garden.
Kickboxing is legal.
It makes no sense at all.
No,
it doesn't make any sense.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's weird.
It's weird that that kind of corruption
is still so transparent and right in
front of everybody
and still you still get politicians to
say nonsensical.
Nonscientific not fact based Shit about
the sport.
And because of the fact that most people
are ignorant to the sport,
you can get away with saying stupid,
ridiculous,
nonscientific Shit and you don't lose
your job.
You know what the fuck's his name?
Whatever the guy's name is the one main.
I don't even want to mention them.
The main guy in New York that's
constantly talking bad about a mma.
Yeah.
The guy that's been paid off by the
union,
like that guy is wrong like all the time
when he describes it,
how he is,
he doesn't sit down with anybody and
have debates on it about the safety
aspect of it,
of you know,
what,
what the,
what tests involve and how it compares
to other shit like Nascar racing or
football or you know,
all different things that we accept that
have shown to cause death and horrible
injury.
And that's just a part of life in
competition.
We're,
we're fine with that.
But for this one thing,
you're telling everybody that they can't
do it.
You're telling everybody why are you
being paid by the Culinary Union?
Yeah,
you are.
Well what the fuck?
Like why it should be,
get the fuck outta here.
Everybody should go.
You're fired.
First of all,
it should be on the front page of the
news.
Did you know that this guy has this
opinion?
He's being paid whether his opinions not
scientifically based ridiculous and
doesn't support the.
The opinion of his constituents and he's
being paid by this union that is trying
to keep the UFC out in New York.
You'd go,
well,
you've got to get that guy out of
office.
That guy's a fucking scumbag.
He's corrupt,
but it's
still going on.
Allowed live stronger than a quiet truth
unfortunately.
And the age of the Internet.
These motherfuckers.
So.
So what's next for you guys?
You have king mo this week,
Thursday night this week.
Is it Thursday night?
Yes,
against premise law.
My clo,
which sounds like some kind of like a
bacterial infection.
Something he might have picked up.
It might my Seattle Polish side of his
balls and then Carl versus Ben Aspirin
will.
And then we have to start at 170 pound
tournament.
That guy,
man,
that's.
That guy is a wrestling fool dude.
Six to.
Is it just takes you down and take you
down,
but you got to have to figure out how to
have like a Marcello Garcia type ground
game to deal with that guy half maybe,
but I mean at the,
his,
his grappling,
his wrestling is so fucking good.
He can just keep holding you in
positions you don't want to be in.
He's great and scrambles and is just as
his wrestling ability and his tech.
Yeah.
It's a wrestling fan.
If you found an Olympian,
and I remember watching Ben when he was
in the,
in the NCAAS wrestling,
Missouri and then uh,
and the Olympics,
I'm watching Ben and his style is so
funky that even if you found an Olympian
and went,
okay,
this will be my training partner.
Get ready for this.
He's not going to wrestle like,
been asking him.
He's just weird shit.
Totally.
When everybody goes to the right,
he goes to the left and then it goes
under you and you're like,
what is going on?
Yeah,
exactly.
And you know,
he's deceptively strong too and you see
that a lot like guys to like physically
they look like these beasts and he
locked Lima.
Yeah,
exactly.
To the moon.
And you're like.
And he told me and everybody keeps
telling me the same thing.
And if you're gonna fight,
Ben have to understand you're going to
get taken down.
You spend some time on your back.
Yeah.
They make this line in the sand where
Douglas,
he told me,
he goes,
I felt so good.
I was like,
there's no way this guy's gonna take me
an hour.
And he threw me and I went,
oh shit,
it's going to be a long night.
Dan Hormonal told us,
he said,
I'm going to stop his take down for two
minutes and then I'm going to beat his
ass up.
He couldn't stop it for 10 seconds and
they just mentally kind of give up
because I go,
shit,
I was supposed to stop this and I can
stop this at all.
You have to accept I'm going to be on
my.
But at some point in this fight,
I think he can get married.
Important.
I think those guys are very important to
the ultimate goal,
which is to figure out what is the best
way to approach any situation and I
think if you look at like the kind of
textbooks that they have available now
in football where they've got every
fucking play documented,
they have all these variations on the
plays,
different things that have changed
during plays that have made them more
successful or errors that were committed
during these players and they have it
broken down in a real scientific
professional way and I think for a guy
like Ben Aspirin,
I think that exposes this new,
this new level of of wrestling ability,
this really unusual Olympic quality
wrestling that nobody seems to be able
to deal with.
Okay,
you have a problem.
How you solve it.
What is it?
Is it,
is it another wrestler?
Is it a kickboxer?
What do,
what is it a guy who's got a nasty
guard,
Shinya Yogi type guy will let them take
them down and then just trap some.
What is it that you have to do to get
past that style because that fucking
style,
whether or not you think it's boring or
not,
a lot of people think it's boring,
it's super effective,
and the reality of a fight is that what
is effective is what's good and
someone's gonna have to figure out how
to stop that.
And it's super important to have a guy
like that,
a guy who couldn't do shit to everybody
that no one wants them to do to them.
And the thing is is that Demian Maia,
I know a 40 fought Weidman,
he said I'm the best mixed martial
artist I've ever been any last.
Like it's almost like when you started
becoming a mixed martial artist,
he kind of got away from what made him
good and he started losing fights and
Ben never does that.
Yep.
Bingos,
I'm a wrestler.
I'm gonna.
Take you down.
I'm a ground and Patty,
I'm using my Jujitsu.
He says,
I'm getting all these other skills,
but I don't take it until you can stop
me.
He also,
Stanford gets away from that mentality
of a wrestler.
He never get the strength is the
takedown.
See,
that's the key to that description.
Damien Maia is not a strong takedown
guy.
I mean he has done some things like when
he.
He hit that lateral drop on Chael Sonnen
and wound up triangle and that was a
beautiful take down,
but the reality is he could not take
down Anderson,
so he's got whooped on for five rounds
or at least three and then two rounds of
chasing them.
But
do you watch that and then you see the
two of them move around.
You're like,
you know what?
I don't see any scenario or Damien Maia
can take down Anderson Silva,
unless Anderson's injured.
Anderson's takedowns,
his,
his defense to good speed is too good.
His technique is too good and his
striking is too fucking scary and you're
not.
Your timing's going to be off because
you didn't worry eating a flying
knee that you didn't think anybody could
ever reach you with.
Anderson reaches him with a knee.
In that fight,
there's a flying knee that he hits
Damien Maia with where he leaps halfway
across the Octagon and connects with his
chin.
And you just like,
how did he get that far?
It doesn't even make sense.
It's like a Michael Jordan type jump
where you see them jumping to go.
How the fuck did he cover that much
distance?
Carlos Newton,
the timing of his flying knee calls
coming in and pride.
Yeah,
cleaned his ass,
caught them clean.
And that was after getting really
dominated on the ground and Carlos
mounted them and you know Carlos really
was eating him up [inaudible] the ground
game.
But it's that combination of,
you know,
the abilities is what makes Anderson so
fucking spooky said he can defend
himself on the ground.
And then when you get to standing up
with them,
oh look,
you're in deep shit now he can do shit
to you that you can't do to him.
And it's his ability to evade physical
pressure.
You can see that bond or tried to do it.
You should try to do it.
Kind of put physical pressure on him.
And he's so elusive and invasive.
That's the hard part is trying to kind
of pin him.
You're not going to get them out a pin
him down and make them feel the
strength,
hard to do.
Only she'll send it.
It affect effect and we need a guy in
that division like Ventura was a real
threat before that fight.
You're like,
well,
you know what?
[inaudible] has some fucking serious
hand speed.
He's putting,
putting knuckles to a lot of dudes and
you know anybody that stands in front of
him when he catches him with that same
blitz,
he hit vandelay width or rich Franklin
or Akiyama,
you know,
you,
you know that he could do that to
anybody.
But after that,
after Anderson knocked him out with a
front kick to the face,
you're like,
okay,
well we'll.
Who's,
who's,
who's scary for him now?
There's no been scary for them right
now.
Maybe Weidman.
Weidman's a beast.
He's a tough.
Why?
One's well rounded and physical and.
But he,
he doesn't.
You don't go,
okay,
this is the tool he's going to use
necessarily like at least a tough dude.
It'd be as wrestling but have to be as
wrestling.
It'd be beating them once again or
submitting.
I'm trying to submit them and he's
fucking cock strong.
Let that.
Why been totally so big boy has a real
struggle to get 85,
but we're talking about you have three
divisions.
I think UFC one 71 and five and tool
five where the.
The the battle to see who gets the title
shot is a lot more interesting than the
title fight itself because you have
dominant champion.
Those divisions away.
I'm really excited about a few different
fights at one 70,
but I'm.
I'm really,
I'm really excited.
Every time I see Johnny Hendricks that
fucking did obese,
he is just listen on you.
He's hitting due to these punches.
Were you like,
what are there like,
is this like a stun gun at the end of
his hand or something?
Like what's happening?
If only he could wrestle.
Oh wait.
Yeah.
Okay.
Shit.
Well,
not only that,
the thing that people don't know about
Johnny Hendricks is fucking Jujitsu is
ridiculous.
He taps people like crazy in the gym.
It just,
he hit so hard that he doesn't even fuck
with that.
When it comes to a fight.
He's,
he's,
he's a scary dude.
I think he's.
He's got the skill set to really give.
Just be problems.
Yeah,
exactly.
If there's one thing I think might be
his Kryptonite is when you put it on GSP
tends ago,
Shit,
he tends to have that backup button.
He goes to his take down,
he goes,
okay,
and goes to his take down.
That might not be there against Johny
Hendricks.
That's why he might have the capability
to,
to actually give you a piece of
troubles.
No one has so far.
If GSP can take down Johnny Hendricks,
people are going to be like,
get the fuck Outta here.
How is that?
His timing is awesome.
Struggled,
struggled with I shields.
Really didn't know.
I mean,
granted he did get poked.
John Fitch,
fitch down some good guys.
Josh Koscheck
Fuck John Fitch up on the feet though
and he had him hurt from,
from punches.
Fitch is another guy that's like man,
what heart,
what determination?
But his physical prowess,
his,
his athletic ability lags slightly
behind guys like GSP.
Yeah,
I know he's worked hard on that.
That was something that he like looked
at after that fight and try to improve
upon,
but how much can you improve upon how
much of a Mesomorph you are?
You look at a guy like gsp,
like especially after he came back from
his knee injury and he started doing
gymnastics to get swole
strong as shit and can't get great
timing.
Timing between striking and grappling.
You never know what the Fox coming.
He mixes it all up.
He's not predictable and he's smart and
he's always in shape and after that Matt
Serra fight.
He's never gonna fuck off again.
You know he fucked off one time.
He gets starched and you realize,
okay,
you got to take every fight.
One hundred percent serious you.
That was the wake up call.
Yeah.
You have to be a professional.
Know.
What do you think about June junior dos
Santos in Cain Velasquez.
What'd you think about that fight?
I thought junior dos Santos got years
beating off his career.
Yeah.
Honestly,
I looked at that and I'm going,
please can just hit him hard enough one
time for them to stop this [inaudible].
There's was a few times ref was going
give me a reason to stop this fight and
Desantos to his credit,
I don't want to say stayed in the fight
because he didn't.
Exactly.
He wasn't competitive but didn't go
down,
didn't get finished,
but it would've been better for him if
that had been stopped in a second round.
Quite honestly he got beat so bad,
but when you go back to the drawing
board,
if you're a junior,
dos Santos has camp and you go back to
the drawing board.
He got taken down,
he got beat up on the feet.
He got outworked,
his cardio wasn't there,
so it's kind of like,
okay,
we have six things we've got to fix.
It's not like he took it,
like when when he knocked out cane,
they could go cane,
keep your damn hand up or whatever.
I know he had a knee injury,
but there are things you could fix.
There's a tweak.
You can make there about seven tweaks.
They got to make the junior dos Santos
after that fight will pass.
Not He's his.
The latest is that he's going through a
divorce and that's why he was not in the
right frame of mind,
but that didn't make any difference.
What kind did cain?
Cain was a monster.
He was a monster.
He dropped me.
Crack them with that right hand.
That's the super aids back there.
You hear that shit.
Trying to stay away from.
That's the exact opposite of what junior
dos.
Santos and Cain Velasquez having life,
right?
Exactly.
You're super aids.
You're the polar opposite of those guys.
Little esther logged into Amazon on my
ipad and so now I've adding all these
things
to her wishlist,
like black anal beads and dildos and sex
and what a sweetheart.
What a good guy.
While we're here talking about fights.
You fucking weird.
I was bummed out that Alistair overeem
pissed off because I really wanted to
see that fight.
Let's talk about that.
I want to talk about this.
We talked about steroids before and the
tone of the conversation.
Everybody said what you just said right
now.
Just thought we're not going to see that
fight.
The tone wasn't that dirty.
Cheater at Oberlin.
No one got on their moral high horse
about it.
Everybody just went,
God damn it.
I want to go see that fight.
Well,
it was just like,
oh,
everybody wants to see that.
And it confirmed what everybody always
suspected about Alastar.
How's it possible?
That big?
Well then Paul Harris just pissed off.
No,
and the other guy we were talking about
ridiculous physique.
He just pissed hot.
Remember when Vito got into UFC
heavyweight?
Yeah,
like the muscle was glued onto him.
He was always one 85.
Your frame holds.
All right.
I walk around,
I walk around like one 85 to 35 pounds
of that muscle to do it.
That is ridiculous.
That's crazy.
That's 55 pounds.
That's 35 pounds of muscle that doesn't
belong there.
That's inside.
And he gas against Randy.
Whoa,
that's insane.
C'Mon dude.
It's a backpack with 50 pounds and it
you can earn 55 fucking pounds of muscle
muscle.
Having a hard time believing that,
but it's true.
Yeah.
When he fought randy,
he looked like a lion.
It was unbelievable.
His head looked like a zit on top of a
mountain Atlantic.
He was gigantic back then.
Yeah,
one 85 is the right way class for him.
We never had knocked out power to a
five.
Like he could stun you with the speed,
but at one point five hits your wants
and you don't know where you are and he
never had that until five,
but he's like a blitzer but you know
down him training now down in Florida
with that Blackzilians team,
Vito has always been a sensational
athlete and being with the black
civilians,
they got that Henry who's guy who's
really tacked on gold dust style,
Dutch style striking and that guy is the
one who's been training all those guys
where tyrone spong and I think that
that's going to be really good for
Vittorio to elevate the technical aspect
of his game because you saw it in that
fight with bisping.
He's still got ridiculous abilities.
I mean that fucking left high kick.
That was very quick.
Yeah.
You know,
at since 1997,
you know,
fighting from 1997.
Now here he is in 2013.
I mean,
we're,
we're talking about almost a 20 year
fucking career and the guy still lending
high kicks like that.
Ridiculous.
Yeah.
It was amazing.
Incredible physical abilities.
His problem is always been eight
psychological,
mental,
getting them mentally into the fight and
has always been hard.
There's been fights where he's looked
the second randy fight,
for example,
third one fight.
We didn't,
didn't even look interested in the
second,
fight it to a fight in the UFC.
And he like,
he didn't even look interested in that
fight.
He was mentally beat,
like,
and you know,
that's been his problem in the past has
been,
I think he's got a lot of mental issues
and hopefully he's getting over those.
Yeah,
I think it's adding more dimension to
his game and that's certainly scary.
Certainly gotten better.
Certainly,
you know,
he's,
he could conceivably challenge Anderson
and make things very interesting if he
could avoid getting cracked again,
like he did,
you know?
Um,
and you know,
he could,
I mean,
you look at the,
their scrap on the ground where he was
throwing these wild punches.
None of them landed on Anderson.
Man,
what if one of them did?
It could've.
Things could've been,
and that's a big flood.
If obviously things could have been very
interesting because it was a.
It was quite a go until that front kick
landed to the face.
Yeah,
amazing.
How many dudes are throwing that now,
isn't it?
Everybody's strong.
Nobody through that before every throws
it down,
but they don't set it up properly.
It's kind of like the whole reason it
works is that not a lot of people throw
it and you're not looking for it and
then it comes right up to the guard,
but people don't set it up and they
throw it by itself and you're like,
what was the perfect technique to use
against Vituro in that circumstance too?
Because Vito or had to close the
distance on Anderson to use his hands.
So he was like more inclined to move
forward and more inclined to not give up
ground and box is really heavy on that
front leg.
So it kind of leaning over that and so
he probably thought it was coming to the
gut.
Just going to tighten up real quick and
just get pushed back a little bit and
dome and hit some time riding the
channel.
Oh,
what a highlight reel shot.
Anderson is just a fucking career.
It's just a series of highlight reel
shots,
you know,
freak.
Yeah.
It's,
it's cool to have a guy like that around
though.
I remember when he beat Hillary.
So Sakkara.
Yeah.
That's all fricking old school.
Old School.
I am everyone Takahashi.
Was it Takahashi that condom condom in
the triangle was um,
a,
a desert,
the Casa.
The Casa trying shoes on.
Yeah.
And then was considered by some at the
time,
the best grappler in Japan.
Very good.
Grounder rated,
you know,
super,
super technical.
It just came at the wrong time.
I never really get it all together.
And then that real children flying,
he'll hook that he caught Anderson with.
That was one of the most insane moves of
all time.
Joe Lozan loves that.
He dives that you've won some fights
with him.
Didn't you submit Jason Chamber with an
Inverted Hill again?
It's back quick enough.
Yeah,
Dude.
I looked at him and was like,
are you okay?
Yeah.
No.
Yeah,
that's not a good one.
It's not a good one.
Your shit up was your meniscus up and
sometimes guys don't come back from
that.
Especially meniscus because the inside's
all fucking.
Oh,
they got to put it in there.
It's bad.
They do that.
Now they use cadaver meniscus.
Really just started stuffing,
stuffing dead,
dead peoples.
Uh,
I have a cadaver bones and ligaments.
Really.
One of my acs they.
But it actually becomes a scaffolding.
It's kind of interesting thing.
They do.
Science is amazing,
isn't it?
Madison?
Incredible.
They put you back together again.
I have both my knees put back together
in,
but the right one,
they use a cadaver.
The left one was a Patella tendon graft.
So what it is,
is the cadaver graft.
It sits in there,
and then your body starts building cells
through it.
It works as a scaffolding for your body
to kind of replace all the cells in it
with its own natural cells.
It actually becomes stronger than the
initial acl that got blown out once it's
fully,
completely healed.
I have,
thank God.
No,
no new problems.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Well I did lose a minor stabilizer in my
knee when I was fighting.
James Wilkes,
like,
like a,
like an MCL minor?
No,
no.
On the sides of your knee cap.
Basically these two tendons that Kinda
like button your,
your top and bottom bone together and
mine just popped and just came off so
you don't have one.
I don't have one there,
but a doctor told me,
he goes,
it's not a major stabilizer.
You're fine.
It's funny story.
I was fighting James Wilson and I'm
going for a knee bar on him and we're
rolling around and I hear this loud pop
come from my knee and James had really
good Thai and I went,
I can't stand up limping period.
So I'm rolling for his knee bar and I
wanted in any way but in my head I went,
well either I get this knee bar,
I'm pretty screwed.
So we're rolling around and rolling
around.
We'll run it and I get this knee bar and
I crank it and he taps and I stood up
and I went and raised.
Man.
I walked out of the cage and I got a
couple of steps and I can't walk anymore
and I went,
if all the adrenaline I have in my
system,
I can't walk right now.
This is really bad.
I mean I couldn't get to the car,
but they never surgically,
they don't.
They repair that one or you know,
I guess they can,
but it gets a big deal and they were
like,
well,
you'll be all right.
And it's never given me a problem since
like,
so it healed up in like three weeks.
And then every body I know the trains or
something.
Fuck,
I got very lucky.
My neck,
my neck is the one the only shot that
ever.
Um,
I'll stop sparring is when I get hit on
top of the head.
Alright,
we gotta get Outta here.
This is three hours into our
conversation.
Dude.
We could do this a hundred times about
mma.
We could do this forever.
Listen to culver city,
man.
We went from Ela to bring peace to the
MMA world because there's a separation
boundary.
Belfort or mean between Bella tour in
the UFC.
This like everyone thinks that we have
to be enemies.
I don't kiss a bullshit bank.
We'll sit down and talk some fucking
fight.
I don't get that at all man.
Man.
It's good for the business is good for
the sport.
It's good for the enjoyment.
Like the idea that you shouldn't enjoy
the UFC or I should enjoy bellatore is
ridiculous.
Stupid.
But I want to thank you for being the
guy that I enjoy the most when it comes
to commentary and when,
when I,
when I watched you like what a referee
does,
something stupid and you yell at 'em and
when a guy's going for something and you
call it and you know,
I think you do an awesome job and it
makes watching fights.
Very exciting.
That means a lot to me and I want to say
that Joe Rogan basically blaze the trail
for everybody like me in mma
broadcasting.
You're the king.
I got lucky.
I came along and I,
I,
I didn't have to worry about losing that
Gig because I had another Gig so I could
talk shit works out well.
Worked out well.
We got,
we all got lucky.
Thank you everybody for tuning into this
podcast.
We'll be back tomorrow with David Cho
and our buddy Yoshi,
and then Wednesday will be the return of
Rick Ross,
Rick Ross back in the house,
bitches new new pieces of evidence in
the investigation and he has a new trial
date.
The Rick Ross,
the real rick Ross,
not the wrapper and Rick Ross is selling
tee shirts now that say the real rick
Ross is not a rapper because we told
them to do that on the podcast and he
started doing it.
So he's making money off of a fucking
scandal.
Ladies and gentlemen,
a follow Jimmy Smith on twitter.
It's Jimmy Smith,
m m a.
and you got a website?
Nope.
No,
I don't even have a business card,
bro.
Good for you.
I fucking love it.
I knew I liked it.
Oh Man.
That's how you're supposed to do it.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com.
Go to o,
n n I t use the code name,
Rogan and save yourself 10 percent off
any and all supplements.
Thanks to.
I can't find the website.
Thanks to thanks to blade slinger for
sponsoring our podcast as well,
and you could buy blades slinger on
itunes for $2 and ninety nine cents
kerosene games,
bunch of cool motherfuckers and we're.
We're happy that they're a part of our
podcast and thanks to Tang,
if you go to [inaudible] dot ting.com,
you can save $25 off any phone or
service and if you want to switch over,
go google that thing that Brian was
talking about earlier and find out what
a ballsy move ting done.
Picking $100,000
and putting it into account to give you
your money back when you switched,
where your money is going to get taken
out of your account.
Like they're going to say,
oh,
well if you want to break this account,
it's going to cost you 150 bucks.
Things going to give you that money
bench and then you could apply it and
like essentially like get like a free
year of service for it.
How reverse mine do I talk too much?
Yes,
I do.
That's why I do this.
All right,
because everybody's meant to do
something this life folks.
I'm here to talk some shit.
Alright,
so we'll be back.
We'll be back tonight at 12:30
AM in the morning when ensign.
Anyway,
chocolate Dell's bringing them in here
so we'll see if we can get chuck in
front of the microphone as well,
but answer in any way if you don't know.
Old School mma legend like one of the
original pioneers toe to toe with Igor
vote champion and one of the craziest
fights of all time to play that tonight.
And he also is doing a lot of
tremendously heroic work helping the
people of Fukushima.
He goes back there to these terrible
radiation zones over and over again,
bringing them aid and he's just a cool
motherfucker and I'm honored to have him
on the podcast.
So that's going to be 12:38
AM in the morning.
All right.
Are you dirty forks?
We love the shit out of here and we'll
see you soon.
As Joey Diaz would say,
stay black.